- At about like 2:00 A.M. one night,
I'm like basically naked.
I open the door and there's
just two girls sitting there,
opposite my door.
SpongeBob has been on like
full volume in my room,
it was like, what are you--
- And you're naked.
(upbeat music)
Welcome back to another
episode of Trash Taste podcast.
I'm your host Joey and
with me are the boys,
the British boys, the BBs.
- I thought you only have like
a Neanderthal or something--
- Oh, okay.
- Come Joey anyway.
- What's up residents of cuckfield.
Welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste--
- Okay, I'll take it.
- I didn't expect that.
- If you're actually from cuckfield,
then there you go there's your shout out.
- Today I found out that I was
on a Samsung ad by accident.
I didn't know.
- Oh, yeah, I saw that.
- Oh, yeah, I saw it, you sent
the clip to Sydney, right?
- No, no, I didn't, no, I didn't.
I--
- I saw you re-tweeting
and I'm pretty sure, oh, like--
- Did I say something, I
don't think I said something.
- I don't know.
- I, I--
- That was for your Fivver thing, right?
- So I did a Fivver video
where I became a Fivver
seller and normally, right?
Fivver you get like vastly under charge
that's kinda how basically
this website works.
- Right.
- But I got contacted
by someone who was like,
"Oh, let's do an actual ad."
I thought great this is
amazing content for the video
because I can actually show
people like how to do it.
- My skills.
- Yeah, right, I was like, "I'm flexible."
- Yeah.
- And I asked him a few questions
'cause normally when you do a
commercial with voice acting,
you need to figure out
like the buyout fees.
And depending on basically
how much the ad is gonna play
and how many countries it's gonna play in,
is like how do you calculate a buyout fee.
So this is the normal studio fee,
which is like the doing the work
and then there's the fee
for essentially using
your voice worldwide.
- Yeah.
- And, you know, it
varies a lot like you can,
I know dudes who've gotten
like 50K of one hour.
- Yeah, I mean, you were talking about
like in a previous podcast
episode about the guy
who does the ads for McDonald's.
- Yeah, he lives off just that.
And like, I did a commercial one time
where I got like $8,000
for just one hour of work.
- Was that the boats one?
- Which one was that?
It was a car one, I'll have to find it.
I can get the link.
- No, you said that you did like
a shaving one as well, right?
- Yeah, I've done shaving
one in the past as well.
- Or whatever the fuck it was.
- Yeah, ages ago, ages ago.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And basically, you get paid
like quite a lot for doing these.
And it's like, okay, cool, right?
Nice, nice and I thought,
okay, this commercial seems
kind of small, you know?
It's like this guy just--
- So how much did he pay you?
- I asked 'cause I thought this
ad was like pathetic, right?
(laughing)
I asked for $300.
- Oh!
- 'Cause I was like it's only
gonna take like 30 minutes.
- You were thinking of the content.
That was what on your mind, right?
- I didn't wanna be too greedy
and I really wanted to get it,
so I thought 300 is a
normal like studio rate fee.
Plus like whatever, it's
gonna play on the internet,
it's not a big deal.
And then I actually
had to do like dubbing,
like actual mouth dubbing.
- Yeah, so you actually had
to dub out the entire scene.
- Yes, so I dubbed over the dudes mouth.
- I didn't actually see the ad,
I just saw you like retweeting
it or tweeting about it.
- It's weird, I don't think my voice fits
the dude that well.
- It was so weird watching it
'cause I was watching the ad
and I didn't know what the process was,
but what it felt like was,
remember watching like
those old Hong Kong movies
where it was like badly dubbed
lip flaps like over the film.
- It's like some cow shit.
- Yeah, exactly, that's what it was.
- Yeah, yeah, it's not bad, I mean--
- I mean, he was still
saying what you were saying.
- Yeah, yeah, it just I think
the problem is, is that like,
especially 'cause everyone knows my voice.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- The problem is that like,
everyone knows my voice
and that's not what you
hear when you hear my voice.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Normally if, you know, you
don't really know the person,
you know, 90% people are gonna
hit the ad aren't gonna be
like, "Oh, yeah, yeah,
that's normal ad, no biggie."
But people know me are
like, "What the fuck!
Like what the fuck!"
- 'Cause it was so weird we're
hearing your voice come out
of like a really old man
or something like that.
- I've done that before though.
Like that's really like nothing.
- So it was like legit Samsung?
- It's like a Samsung ad, yeah.
I don't know what it's for, but-
- Then they got like
the deal of the century.
- Yeah, I was fucking ripped off.
Yeah, I mean, I priced what
I thought was fair based on
what the seller had told me.
- Right.
- And if I knew it was gonna be Samsung
and it's gonna be like
worldwide like that,
I mean we all would've had (indistinct)
- You thought you were playing them,
but in the end they were playing you man.
- I was getting played, yeah.
- They played you.
- I said, "Why the fuck is
Samsung hiring five voice actors?
What the fuck!"
- Yeah, you think that they'd
got to like professional--
- Yeah, it's a little
- Not to say that, you know,
some voice actors aren't professional.
- Hearing more stories makes me wonder
how many big industry companies
are like going on these small sites,
you know, like hiring Fiverr voice actors,
going like putting job ads
on Craigslist whatever.
- Yeah, I think what's happening--
- Right Raelynn?
(laughing)
- That hurts, what I do
you think happens is that,
okay, so Samsung is there
like, "Listen, guys,
we have a genius advertisement here.
We want a company to handle it."
They go and find and ad agency
and then that agency is like,
"We know just the guy."
They pretty hire another agency
who then pretty hires the final agency
that actually makes it and then
they've got like no budget.
So they're like get the
Fivver voice actors.
Because I'm not gonna lie a
lot of Fivver voice actors
are really fucking good and
getting charged like nothing.
- Yeah, I mean, I would argue
that like almost everyone
on that website is probably
a little too overqualified
for what you're paying for.
- Yeah, that's how that website works.
- I mean they're either overly qualified
or they're heavily under qualified.
- That's true.
- There's no in between.
- They'll be people like
a Blue Yeti that are like,
"Yeah, I guess I can give you
the commercial rights to it,
and, you know, 50 more
words are gonna run,
ah, Jesus, 400 bucks man."
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's like, "Bro what the fuck!"
- I've had that with like artists as well
where some of them are
just like fucking goatee
where it's like you
should make an art book
and then other people are like,
"Just started a Deviant
Art two days ago let's go."
- $100 per commission, let's go.
And it's such a coin flip because
even if they have like
a good portfolio, right?
I've had experiences where
I've hired like artists
to produce like an artwork
or music or something
and it is not up to the level
they put on their portfolio
or their public portfolio.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- You can tell he was
like, here's my A list work
and you're just getting
the D list work on Fiverr,
you know what I mean?
- 'Cause you're not paying me
like $500 or some bullshit.
- Same with the voice acting as well
'cause a lot of people get
their demos done in a studio
like formally like mixed,
produced professionally
and that kind--
- Yeah.
But then when they do it at home,
they're just like (indistinct)
- They get their fucking Blue
Yeti set up in a hotel room
and it's like, "All right."
(laughing)
- They're just like this is shit.
- I don't know if this is
what I paid for, you know,
say that's how I got fucking scammed.
I don't know, I mean, I got
paid, hey, I didn't get scammed.
It's my bad like--
- Yeah.
- Well played Samsung in advertisement.
- Did you record this commercial shoot
or was the commercial
recording in your own room?
- Yeah, in my own room.
- Okay.
- And I did it like I,
I didn't do any of the trimming actually
'cause they wanted to do it
so it was pretty painless.
The only thing was is that like,
because the lip flaps
they had like fucking,
of course they zoomed in
on this man's fucking face,
so the lip flaps was so pronounced
so you can see exactly which syllable
in which letter he was on so.
- Yeah.
- And there was one where they
sent me where they were like,
"Hey, can you change the
script on this one line?"
I'm like, "No, the man's
lips say this thing.
What do you mean can I change the script?
I can't fucking change it to what you,
you've added in like three more words.
How do you think I'm gonna do that?"
- Yeah, you should have
done it just to really
like drive on to like home
the Kong power of it, right?
It's like--
- I should have just sent
to them been like this is what you wanted,
this is what you asked for,
this just 300 bucks by
the way, this is what you.
(laughing)
- That would have been hilarious.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like the lip
flaps clearly say like,
"I love Samsung."
But you just can't change
it to like, "Buy Apple."
(laughing)
- 'Cause it's like the next
level from anime dubbing, right?
'Cause with anime dubbing--
- It's so much harder than anime dubbing.
- Yeah, with anime dubbing
you have to match all like
the lip flaps of the syllables.
- So it's two frames, right?
It's open mouth with close mouth, right?
- No, three frames actually.
Yeah, I know this
because I have to edit
lip flaps in a bridging
'cause in a bridging it's easy
'cause you take you take your script
and you just fucking edit
these three frames of mouth.
There's closed mouth, half
opened and fully opened.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But with dubbing you obviously
can't edit the lip flaps
or anything like that so you just,
sometimes you hear some lines
and it's really, it's a really
unnatural line, you know,
but you just gotta match
what the animation is.
- Right.
- Yeah, it's really like makes you,
as if you trying to do it,
it really makes you fucking
appreciate these like,
in the countries where they
mainly dub a lot of the imagery
that they import like how
fucking insane that is
that they managed to do
like full seasons of shows
and like it's not terrible.
It's so hard because you're so constrained
with other mouth shapes because, you know,
I mean, you have to exactly copy.
And luckily this was English,
but like, oh my god, another language.
- Meanwhile you have countries like Japan
that it just like fuck that.
- Yeah, I have noticed Japan
is just like fuck the lip
flaps, let's just talk over it.
- That's what makes it like a
million times more hilarious.
- [Garnt] Yeah, I know, right?
- The change in the voices
is already hilarious
but then seeing them like
say something that just
not a single mouth movement is correct.
- You almost like don't mind it though
'cause you realize they're
just like they're not,
they're not trying to do that.
It's like, yeah, whatever
man, I don't give a shit.
I'm supposed to be sent
like fucking, some fucking
like History Channel Car
restoration show on TV.
And they had like,
it was like a really like old British guy
and they had like the proper
like Samurai sounding old dude.
(indistinct)
I was like, "Wow, okay, geez."
That's not what he, I mean,
that's what he sounds like,
but I don't know, I'm like, cool.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- That was kind inappropriate.
- That's how the old dude
sound like a Japanese
like Munna, Munna, Munna, Munna.
Like I don't even know what to say.
- Did you say Munna Munna?
- I think he just did.
- Munna Munna Munna.
(laughing)
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- Fuck it no, they don't
do that, total shit.
- Speaking of Munna, did we
talk about that time we went
to a Jojo bar last week or?
- I don't think we did so.
- So, yeah, 'cause I wanted
to talk about the Jojo bar so.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, to explain like two weeks ago,
we went to the same Jojo bar
that Joey made a video on.
And it was fucking,
I don't know what it is about Japan
that has so many of like these small bars
that are like, themed,
but they're like way cooler
than any of like the,
like the big bars that
you go to in the West
or that I've been to like in
England that tried to make
like this themed bar, you what I mean?
'Cause it was so small
and it was so intimate
and it was run by a guy
who clearly really fucking love Jojo.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, yeah.
- And I think the thing what
impressed me the most was
the fucking drink list.
- Oh my god, it's gigantic.
- Holy fuck!
- Yeah, like the, because
in my video as well
and when we got there they
say that you can film anything
and you can take photos and videos
of like any of the merch
or anything like that,
but you can't take a picture
or video of the menu.
For the longest time I
never understood why?
Like why only the menu?
But then when you actually
flip through this menu
and you realize there's like,
almost like 1000 fucking drinks.
- I think there's like, there's gotta be,
I'm counting my head like maybe like
around 300 drinks I think.
- Yeah.
- I'd say so.
But it's like more than
like your conventional
like bar thing.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And out of those like three 400 drinks,
half of them are originals.
It just says original.
And they're all like named
after, you know, characters
and phrases and whatnot.
And you have to fucking like
perform the phrase as well
to the bartender.
And it's so like embarrassing
when like you say
like lines like, "Excuse me,
can I get the (indistinct)."
And then she's like,
"Okay, one (indistinct)."
(laughing)
- Coming right up.
- It's so cool.
- Here's your (indistinct).
- Yeah, because to explain
how the menu works,
basically the menu works
like, like a fucking,
the menu is the Jojo reference, right?
So it goes by parts.
So every drink is either named
after a character or a stand
or just a random reference.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, you know, you have like
a random catchphrase or something.
Was there like a drink in
part four that was like,
let's kill da ho or something like that.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- Let's kill the hoe.
- Let's kill the hoe, bitch.
(laughing)
- There was like a reference to like
the dead dog in part one
and one of them was Wells
or was it something--
- Oh, yeah, it was like
Danny or something.
- That was his name, yeah.
- Yeah or something like that.
- Something like that
and then that was like,
Oh my god, there was just
so many funny sounding ones
like I just loved those
one Bohemian Rhapsody.
I mean, that's a stand.
I just loved that I could
order a drink called
a Bohemian Rhapsody.
- Yeah, I just found it
super cool that I was just
basically ordering a fucking,
you know, Kira Yoshikage
or something like that.
You know, you just basically
ordering Jojo references
and I thought that was fucking brilliant.
- Although there was one thing
that I was like kind of upset about
and I don't know if this
is gonna be a spoiler
for part seven, but I was very upset
that I couldn't order a Jesus Christ.
- Oh yeah, I would have
liked the Jesus Christ.
- I was looking through part seven,
I'm like please say
there's a drink I'll try.
- Was there a President of
the United States as well?
I don't think there was either.
- I don't know, no, though I
think there was a, was there?
- I mean, there was Funny Valentine.
- There was Funny Valentine.
Was there another George Bush?
- George Bush.
(laughs)
- Right, 'cause he's a
Canon character, right?
That he appears.
- I don't know, I probably don't remember.
- Or it's like a character
that's mortal or something,
I don't fucking know but--
- See what I love about being a Jojo fan
is you only watch the anime
hanging out with you two.
We have like red way further in the manga,
is that I was hanging out to this bar
and you were just like straight
up putting out spoilers
of part six and part seven.
And the great thing about Jojo
is that I was listening to these
spoilers and I'm just like,
"I don't think I've actually
been spoiled at all honestly."
- It is just the only
show that you can spoil
without actually giving anything away.
- It makes so little sense
that when you hear it,
it's like you just
don't see it ever coming
when you're reading it.
- Yeah, so in part seven
Dio turns into a dinosaur
because he's going off to Jesus Christ arm
and you're just like, "I
guess that's what happens."
- I mean, that was my
exact same like reaction.
- I knew that happened but I didn't,
like when I was reading
it I was like, "Oh!"
And I only realized it when
it was happening I was like,
"Oh, that's what everyone meant."
(laughing)
- 'Cause out of context it's like,
how is this plot point supposed to fit
into this story in any sense.
- Hearing it out of context it's just,
it doesn't hinder your enjoyment
when you're actually
experiencing the entire thing,
which is why I'm fucking
looking forward to when,
I'm hoping when part six,
part seven has animated.
- Oh yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Although hearing you guys
talk about it in the bar,
I might just like go out
and read it honestly.
- It's so good dude, it's so good.
- Part six to seven manga
is fairly incredible.
- I'm a Jojo like cock JoJo
or cock sucker whatever,
so it's like I mean, I've (indistinct).
- That was Jojo fan basis
comment, JoJo cock suckers.
(laughing)
- That's basically what they are.
What is it with all the memes
where it's like a Jojo fans
when they see it on the
site cock or whatever
is what it is, is fucking memes.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like the best part is though is it like,
you don't know if the drink,
like this is just like original, right?
So you have no idea what it
is, but you kinda gotta guess
is it gonna be like a
fruity easy to drink drink
or is it gonna be like
just fucking alcohol
like straight liquor,
unlike Joey just somehow kept ordering
like just he was like, "I'll have the Ri
and the Ora Ora Ora and
they were all just like
basically straight spirits.
I kept ordering stuff
that was all like Malibu's
fruity drinks, I was like--
- I actually think he has a kind of like
a power leveling system
going on with the drinks
'cause anytime you'd ordered
like a main character
or like a JoJo, it was always
a super powerful drink.
- Yeah, I know like out of
all the powerful drinks I had,
I think the most powerful one I had was--
- Stroheim.
- No, it was part three Dio.
- Wasn't it really the Ri was
like really straight vodka?
- Ri as well was fucking
bad and I'm like--
- You had to actually
order a drink by going,
"Ri toxic on this house."-
- And then this cute
bartender girl was like,
"Okay, Ri that's toxic."
- But here's the thing, do you
think he actually remembers
every drink that he made 'cause
most of them are originals?
- I think so.
- I mean he has to, right?
- Oh wait, when you order
the Yoshikage Kira as well,
it comes with a separate hand.
- Oh, it came with a separate hand,
which I thought was fucking brilliant.
- And the Sex Pistols.
Sex Pistols comes on like a
roulette like style table thing
with a gun in the middle
and that's actually cool.
- And it's like just different shots.
- It's just basically six shots.
- Which is perfect about shoots shot.
- So you go to the menu you one,
you don't know how strong
the drink is gonna be
and like two, you don't
know what the drink
is gonna be either so it
was just a fun experience
just working your way through the menu
and just being like, hey, this is a Kira
or this is like Sex Pistols
and just being surprised
at what you got basically.
- But I think as well
that's such an awesome
like marketing move as well
because that just incentivizes
you to go back to it.
I was being like, "All
right, I finished all
the part one drinks this time round,
next week I'm gonna go back
and finish all the part
two drinks all right.
- It's basically like
watching Jojo itself.
You walk through each part
until you get through every part.
- You can't skip any of the parts,
you have to like complete it.
(laughing)
- I had like five Rohan Kishibe.
It was like Rohan Kishibe at the store,
Rohan Kishibe at the Lourve.
- Yeah, no, it was like Rohan
Kishibe goes to Gucci, right?
That's was one of the drinks.
- Yeah, I was like how many
Rohan Kishibes are there?
What the fuck!
- You know what, my favorite
one was when you ordered
like a Jotaro and you have to like specify
which parts are, which part
Jotaro are you ordering?
- That's was awesome, yeah.
It's like I don't know,
I feel like those kinds of establishments
are just the most perfect place
to just weeb the fuck out, right?
Because it's like if forgives
you for weebing out, right?
- You get so drunk as
well 'cause you're like,
you just wanna keep fucking drinking
and it's like reasonably priced,
it's like I don't know like $7 a drink.
- Yeah, and all the cocktails
are delicious as well,
you know, they taste really,
really good even though,
you know, half of them fucked me up
because they were so fucking strong.
- You just kept getting the straight shot
and I kept getting the nice ones
and I was like, "Oh, yeah."
- I was like, "I want
something nice to just
like sooth my throat off
all these fucking shots
you know what I'm saying?
- I kept ordering these fucking Sex Pistol
and it just gets, it's
just straight up six shots,
it's not even a cocktail.
- I love it.
(laughing)
- That was good.
- But yeah go check it out
if you guys are at Nakano.
- What was it called again?
- It's called a-
- Dio, right?
- It called Dio, yeah, in Tokyo.
- So when the country opens
up, gonna pay them a visit.
They have a Twitter as well, like Dio bar.
- Yeah, they have a Twitter.
- Yes, right now in Nakano Broadway,
which if you're gonna come to Japan,
I reckon like a lot of weebs
come to Japan and they're like,
"We need to go to Akihabara,
we need to Akihabara."
But I reckon like Nakano Broadway
is also a very, very much
- It's fun and awesome, yeah.
- It's kind of like the
underground version of Akihabara.
- It's like a condensed Akihabara.
- Yeah, exactly 'cause
everything you can get.
Most of the things you get in Akihabara
just condensed down into one building
and you can basically walk
around it for a lot less time
than you would Akihabara.
- Yeah, there's just, I don't know,
there's just like in Nakano Broadway.
I feel there's just a lot
more like interesting,
like old Tokyo stores like
very, very niche stuff
that like you might not
necessarily be into it,
but it's just really
fucking interesting to see.
- Because the thing
about Akihabara is that,
once you've been once you
see what the former is,
you know what I mean?
You see what shows get on display,
it's all like the Moe stuff normally
and, you know, it's a lot
more difficult to find
a lot of the nicher shows
and kind of like figurines or merchandise
that are like less mainstream.
But in Nakano Broadway,
you find a lot of like untapped gems,
unlike, there's really good store there.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
There's this fucking
store in Nakano Broadway
that's like right at the
entrance of Nakano Broadway
that sell Gengars from the anime.
And like they sell like Cels from anime.
- Right, oh, I saw that one, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like what the fuck, yeah.
- I mean, like some of
these Cels are quite cheap
because they're probably like
mass produced the one that,
which is just based on shows
that no one really cares about,
but some of the more expensive ones
are just like holy shit.
- Yeah, I remember there was a Cel from
The End of Evangelion that I saw from the,
it's in the top floor of Nakano Broadway,
if I remember correctly,
and it's right at the back.
But they have some like
really classic Cels.
The most impressive one
I saw was one from like,
The End of Evangelion,
and it was the Asuka's flight as well.
- Oh, shit.
- And it was an expensive boy.
- Yeah, I get it.
- How much was it?
It was like, I think it was like $10,000.
- Oh!
- Yeah, that sounds about right.
- For a piece of paper.
- I mean, at that point is
basically like a museum--
- Oh, no, that's true, that's true.
- How can you put a price?
- How do they get that?
- That's what I wanna know, right?
- How does that like get
in the hands of someone?
- It's just like maybe
they'd like sell those often
like auctions or--
- Maybe some staff member takes it
and then they sell it on--
- It's like, "It's only one
Cel they wouldn't know."
- Like, "Hey man, this
Crunch is brutal man,
I'm gonna take a little something home,
make a little bit of cash
on the side, you know?"
- There's a snitch in the studio,
we'll take it out ourselves.
- I think they're only just
gonna get more expensive because
now animation studios don't
use Cel animation anymore.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- So at this point it just becomes like
a memorabilia, right?
Of our history because you can't,
I mean, you can get like Gengars
and everything like that,
but having a good old fashioned
Cel is just not a flex.
- Yeah, because you can't
like, unlike a Gengar,
you can't like, you know,
photocopy a Cel, right?
Because it's based off
like a plastic sheet.
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's much easier to tell
when a cell is completely fake
'cause I've seen some
fucking completely fake Cels
and it's just like all these
like flimsy pieces of paper
and people paying stupid
amounts of money for it
because they don't know any better, right?
I'm just like, "No,
don't, what are you doing?
It's just a fucking drawing."
- Do you guys miss the old
like Cel animation aesthetic
compared to like much cleaner
digital aesthetic of today?
- No.
- It's been bittersweet
for me I think like,
obviously like, you know,
the digital stuff now
is like so much better
choreographed unlike the later ends.
Like you can tell that
like all these camera movements were done
through a computer.
But I don't know there's
something really charming
about like, you know, a
manual like camera shake
in terms of making a Cel.
- Ed, Edd n Eddy great animation.
(laughing)
- Old Cels.
- Dude man I love that,
I love the bubbly lines,
you know, I mean, it's great.
- It's comfy, it's comfy.
- Yeah, I mean, like Redline was all-
- That was great, that was-
- That's fucking, oh my God.
- And that took like what 10 years?
- Seven years.
- Seven years, yeah.
- It took a little while,
it took a little while.
- But yet no one fucking watched it.
- Yeah, I mean, I will say
that I think, you know,
on average animation is better quality now
because digital animation has made things,
has made it easier to get
a higher level quality
of animation for like most animes.
But yeah, I think you're right,
there is like a definite charm
about watching good old
fashioned Cel animation.
- Yeah, I definitely
wouldn't want all my anime
to be based off Cels, but--
- No.
- There were some like,
especially like when you go back
to like, you know, the whole like '80s
just like general anime
aesthetic, that like the,
"Oh yeah, this is an '80s
anime goal aesthetic."
Like that on Cel animation is just-
- It's like a bowl of like Rice Krispies.
Like, I never eat a fucking
bowl of Rice Krispies
when I do I'm like,
all right, okay, yeah--
- It's not bad.
- Okay.
- Not bad.
(laughing)
- But then the next day, you're like,
"I don't even think about Rice Krispies."
That's how I see it, do
you know what I mean?
(laughing)
- I don't but I'll just nod.
- I don't give a fuck about it.
- I'll just nod and agree.
(laughing)
I know literally zero things about cereal.
I don't eat cereal.
- Yeah, me neither.
That's why it's like, it just
kind of reminds you being
a kid again, you know what I mean?
- I don't fully agree with you.
I'll just use analogies all right.
(laughing)
I'll just assume that like your fucking--
- That's what old Cel
animation reminds me of like
a bowl of cereal, right?
I don't eat cereal 'cause--
- [Joey] Right.
- Frankly, I don't care for it.
There I said it, okay?
Controversial pitch.
- No, it's not controversial.
- [Joey] It's not controversial.
- Here's a controversial
thing when I do eat cereal,
I don't eat it without milk,
I'd eat it without milk.
- That's what I'm saying, yeah.
- I want my cereal dry, I
think the milk ruins it.
- It's better than folk
people who say like,
fucking monsters who say like,
"Oh yeah, I use water in mine."
- Okay, that is a level
even I was duped too.
- I'm pretty sure that's like how you end
like Jiva convention that
have to do that, right?
And that's like fucked up like--
(laughing)
- Because it's basic human rights.
- Like what?
- Yeah, I do, I knew a guy in--
- That's bullshit.
- I knew a guy my uni, no,
I saw him fucking do it too.
I knew a guy my uni who--
- Did you call the police?
- Dead ass, yeah, I was about to.
(laughing)
I think I'm being assaulted right now.
My eyes are being assaulted.
No, it was fucking disgusting you--
- I never condole like
spitting in someone's food,
but I think that's an
exception to be made.
- Yeah, he was eating like just,
and it was like basic
ass cornflakes as well.
And I'm like it's already
a human rights crime
to just eat cornflakes with nothing in it,
let alone with water.
- Actually I could eat
cornflakes with nothing in it.
- No, it depends on the cornflakes.
- Yeah, but like eating
with water is like-
- That's a, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like here let me top
my water with more water.
- Who likes cereal when
it's the soggiest, right?
'Cause that's all you're doing,
you're just making your cereal soggy.
- Exactly.
- Like were you that
desperate for hydration
that you needed to go for
your fucking cornflakes,
like what the fuck!
- Yeah, that's why whenever
I used to eat cereal
in high school, I would eat
that shit so fucking fast.
- Did he make it through high school
or did he like just not make it?
- I mean, he was in my
uni so I guess he did.
- Oh, shit, okay, wow.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The university took him in?
- I'm like, "Man, like you
can't even afford milk at uni?"
(laughing)
Like are you that much of a--
- I smell broke.
- Are you that much of a broke uni student
that he can't even afford milk?
- You just go to the tap and you're like,
"Here we go again another day."
- I don't know what it is about uni
and like communal kitchens
and the one thing that always gets taken
in the communal kitchens is the milk.
It's always the milk.
I don't know why, everything else--
- Is just because you can just take it
and you think they
won't notice that's why,
but everyone does it.
- Like you can label your cutlery,
you can label your food to be like,
don't touch this, don't touch this.
You can label your milk
but it never works.
Your milk will inevitably
disappear like a day or two,
they'll touch it.
- Yeah, because it's like
a lost currency, right?
It's like water but with calories.
(laughing)
- I remember when I--
- It's water with attitude.
- I had a friend who was
in my dorm and I liked him
and then one time, yeah, I
did like him but now I don't.
- You did.
- I liked him.
- Emphasize the did.
- You know, he was really
high and then I came in--
- Like stoned.
- Yeah, stoned, he was really stoned.
And then I walk in and I see
him eating cookies and cream,
Ben & Jerry's, and I'm
like, "Where's my, is that,
that's not, I could use some
cream and Jerry's is it?"
And he's like, "Oh, sorry.
I'll buy you one tomorrow."
And I'm like, I was
gonna eat that tonight.
(laughing)
I've planned a great
evening watching anime,
I was gonna eat that.
I don't want your shitty
Tesco's one pound,
four kilograms of vanilla
that looks brighter
than like yellow on the
like hexadecimal thing.
I don't want that ice cream
that tastes like shit.
Why would you, that pissed me off so much.
- Yeah, like vanilla ice cream
that's like way too yellow
for its own good scares me.
- Oh, yeah, that aint-
- That's like a fear I have.
I have a fear of heights
and way too yellow vanilla ice cream.
- It doesn't even tastes like ice cream,
it tastes like something,
I don't know what it is like that's--
- It's like I don't wanna eat something--
- What's even worse than that is
when you get the soft serve
and the soft serve isn't
white and it's yellow,
have you ever had that?
- No.
- [Joey] I know I have.
- 'Cause at that point--
- Wait, where did you get that from?
- Okay, it's not like the,
it's it's always just in like
the fucking ice cream vans that
only come out in the summer.
- Oh.
- Oh, I thought you were
talking about in Japan.
- Not in Japan.
- Oh, okay I got it, I was gonna say--
- We get the top tier sheer here in Japan.
- They wouldn't morph it here in Japan
that's a British move.
This episode is sponsored by Postmates.
If you're like me,
you start thinking about
what to eat for dinner
while you're eating lunch.
I love food, but sometimes
getting into my kitchen
and cooking something delicious to eat
just doesn't make it on my to do list
that's why I definitely use Postmates.
- But Connor we live in Japan.
- Joe, Joe, Joe, shh, they're paying this.
- I love Postmates.
(laughing)
- [Announcer] With Postmates
you can get food delivered
without leaving your house or
even opening your front door.
With the current state
of the world in mind,
Postmates created no contact deliveries.
So now when I order
from local restaurants,
everything gets left on my doorstep
and the app lets me know
when it's been delivered.
- I hate humans so this is
the perfect service for me.
- What a privilege to be living
in a world with Postmates.
- Postmates also offer a pickup version
which I've been using
to order off my local restaurants here.
- Good.
(laughing)
- It's so important that we support
and uplift our communities right now
and what better way than
ordering some fine food.
- [Connor] And Postmates isn't just
all about burgers and sushi,
I can order anything from
toilet paper to phone chargers
from stores like Walgreens and 711
and Postmates will drop it off
right outside my front door.
- God I wish I knew this a few months ago,
this would be so useful.
- Just download Postmates
on iOS or Android,
find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered
within the hour that includes condoms.
(laughing)
- [Connor] What?
- Why would you mention that?
- [Announcer] For lovers of
time, Postmates is giving
our listeners $5 off
your first five orders
for your first seven days.
To save $5 on your first five deliveries,
download the app and
use the code TRASHTASTE.
- That's code TRASHTASTE for
$5 off your first five orders
when you download the Postmates
app or sign up online.
- As we all know the Postmates tagline,
"Anything you need, anytime
you need it, Post made it."
- Including condoms.
- Thank you for sponsoring
this episode back to the video.
- In England, sometimes they have
these ice cream vans, right?
That only come out that
one day that it's summer
or that it's sunny and--
- I've never seen them do that though.
- Have you, have you never,
have you ever had the soft serve
from one of those ice cream vans before?
- Yeah, you see it from coming out
of like the machine right?
The flake, right?
- Yeah, it's 99 flake.
And some of them they do come out white,
some of them they come out yellow, right?
And you always know it's
like the shittiest ice cream
'cause it's not even ice cream.
Okay, ice, there's the ice and
the cream and the soft serve.
With this, it's like 70%
cream and like 30% ice.
So it's like, it's not even filling.
- But was it you who said
that you're not a fan of soft serves?
- I think soft serves
tastes too milky, it's like-
- But that's the best bit.
- Nah, dude--
- It is the fact that it's milky.
- It feels like I'm eating
milk, I don't wanna eat milk,
I wanna eat ice cream.
- No, yeah, soft serve
is the best ice cream.
- Gelato, gelato is the best--
- Get the fuck outta here.
Gelato is like eating a three course meal
while eat like in one soft serve.
- I like how gelato can
like crush everything else
in my stomach down to make room.
- Wait, wait so you've never
had like a creamy a premium?
- No, I have, I have.
- Do you like it?
- I think it's too milky.
- You like it, right?
- I mean, it's good
because it's a soft serve,
but I do agree that it's a bit too milky.
I think, I think--
- Japan are obsessed with
milk, I don't know what it is.
- I think humanity peaked in soft serves
and in ice cream in
general with the McFlurry.
I don't know what it is about McFlurry,
but I can eat that shit like for eternity.
- Is the McFlurry a self serve?
- I mean, technically--
- I feel like it's in
its own category of ice.
Like it's not even--
- I mean, out of us three,
you're the only one who
ever worked in McDonald's
that's like unfortunately it's you.
(laughing)
- So it comes out of a machine, right?
That kind of looks like a soft serve.
- Yeah.
- Am I correct?
- I mean--
- Is it soft serve?
- I don't know.
- It's the same ice cream
that they put in the cone
for like McDonald's ice cream.
- Yeah, like the 20 cents ice cream.
- I don't know what it is
about putting a soft serve
in a cup and then putting
some toppings on it
and then fucking spinning it.
I called it spinning, what, mixing it.
I don't know why that's
just the magical formula,
but I remember the first
time I've tasted a McFlurry,
I'm like, I like all these
ingredients individually,
but put them together
and mix them in a separate way and you--
- You McFlurrried in your pants.
- Yeah, I McFlurried in my pants
- Basically.
(laughing)
- I can't even remember this,
but is the milkshake machine
and the ice cream machine the same?
Do they--
- No, no.
- Is it not?
- It's not.
- But it's the same machine, right?
It's like two different settings though.
- I think I've had like three
McFlurries in my life so.
- What?
- Yeah.
- No, because the McFlurry the ice cream,
the ice cream machine in
McDonald's actually works,
the milkshake it's like 70%
of the time, it's not working.
- 'Cause I remember when
I worked at McDonald's,
I'd like refill the milkshake machine
and it was like, it's just like a sack.
Like it's just a sack of fluid, right?
And to fill this up, right?
You have to like hold up
this bag and loosen the cap
and then like pour it in the bag.
Have you ever tried to
pull a string out of a bag?
- Yeah.
- It's like the fucking worst.
Like there's no like faucet or anything,
not faucet, fucking like lid
or anything to direct it,
it's just a fucking hole.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so I'm pouring this thing
and then a little bit obviously
like started splashing off,
and so it started splashing
me like fucking whatever
and I put it all over my fucking
self in front of everyone
and the machine was broken.
- And then everybody came around and--
- The machine was broken for another hour
'cause we had to clean everything up
that I fucking spilled everywhere.
- What was inside the bag?
- It's just like milkshake mix.
It's just like mix.
- So why is the milkshake
machine always breaking?
- They have to clean it constantly.
Like that's when I was there.
Like, they would fucking clean
it every few hours 'cause
apparently, obviously the milk
can get stale really fast.
so they clean it.
- In an hour though?
- No, but it's like they
have to clean it I think
like two times a day at least,
I can't remember 'cause like--
- I mean, I wouldn't be surprised
if the milkshake machine
was basically the same
as the ice cream machine.
And that's because a McDonald's milkshake
is basically a fucking soft serve--
- I agree, yeah , yeah, yeah.
- But you have to drink
it through a straw.
- Yeah, it's a melted soft soft serve.
- So like every time I get
a McDonald's milkshake,
you have this like five
minute grace periods
where it's impossible to
drink the fucking milkshake.
- Yeah, true, true.
- 'Cause you eat-
- That's great 'cause you eat the food
and then you can drink the milkshake.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause you try sucking in it
and the straw just fucking collapses in,
and it's like wait, you know what I mean?
(laughing)
That's like the McDonald's milkshake--
- You create a mini
black hole inside of it.
It's like everything gets crushed.
(laughing)
- Like my brother worked for McDonald's
and when I turned 16 I really
wanted the fucking Xbox One,
so I was like, "I'm gonna
get a job at McDonald's."
You're paid like £4.10
an hour, which is like $5
that was like maybe $5.50.
And, yeah, I fucking hated it.
And I remember my brother
telling me he was like,
"Yeah, you can get sick of
McDonald's food really fast."
And I was like six months in I'm like,
I fucking love this food stuff still like,
you'd get to make your own
like, you weren't supposed to,
but like the managers were
like, "You could have this."
Like you can basically
make your own burger.
So I used to just make like the,
like in the UK we have like
fried chicken sandwiches,
like they're like fancy ones.
They used like the, like
they're like the better meat.
I mean, it still little fucking awful,
but I would just fucking put
like a handful of fucking bacon
and just shove it on and
that was like the best part.
And then you could get like
meals like half priced,
but everything else is
fucking awful at McDonald's.
Everything was awful.
Like, the people were the worst part man.
They were just like--
- More like the workers or the customers?
- Workers, the workers.
- Oh, really, yeah.
- 'Cause I just didn't
get along with any of them
and they will all, you
know, like not to be mean,
but a lot of the ones that I
worked with were like people
that like, I wouldn't be friends with.
- Whenever I go to a McDonald's
and I see like an employee
smiling, I'm like, "He's Cersei."
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like who is he murder today?
So some are just like
orange Cersei right now.
(laughing)
- I remember, I legitimately
got like, I got like put,
had to come sit in the, like
fucking put on like detention
for like 20 minutes 'cause--
- At the McDonald's?
- 'Cause I was working on the fucking,
like making the chicken
burgers and the burgers,
I was making the burgers
and they took me off for not smiling.
And I said, I said, I said,
"Why do I have to smile
when making burgers?"
And they looked at me like,
"Why did you ask that question?"
And they told me to go and
take a break for 20 minutes.
- It was like George Orwell, wasn't it?
- I was like what do you mean?
- Dystopia, everyone has to smile.
- I was like,
"What do you mean I'm
not fucking smiling mate,
I'm making a fucking
burger, what do you mean?"
I couldn't believe it, I was furious.
- Yeah, it's like they're at home,
they make their own
sandwiches they're like,
"Shit, I forgot to smile."
- I couldn't believe it.
And so I was like 16 one time
and the one time when I was like,
I fucking hate it here, was
when they were talking to me
and these dudes were like 25
and they were bragging to me,
like both of them were
bragging to me about
how they were going to a
party in the school next to me
of like 16 year olds.
And I was like, "So you went to a party
full of 16 year olds?"
And they were like, "Yeah, it was sick."
And I'm like, "Why?
Why did you go to a party full
of 16 year old, you're 25?"
And they were like,
"Oh, shit, I wanted to
get with the girls."
I'm like, "What?"
(laughing)
- Yikes.
- In the UK it's legal, 16,
but I was still like what?
What the fuck!
- Yeah, but still.
- And the only nice people
there were the ones above 40,
but at everyone near my age
was just the fucking worst.
And every time I had to
go and train someone,
so I was there for like three
months and after three months,
you're ready to train people,
you're a fucking McDonald's
veteran because you've lasted
more than 90% of the fucking
employees no joke because--
- I believe that.
- Yeah, I believe that but it hilarious.
- Because they hire so
much, they over hire
because they know that
people are gonna like leave.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so I was teaching this one guy
and he was clearly like,
just like not getting it,
you know, didn't wanna get it.
And I could tell he was
like, "Yeah, I'm not gonna,
I'm not gonna listen to this."
So about two hours into his
shift of me teaching him,
he goes, "I'm gonna get a smoke break."
He never came back, he just left.
(laughing)
He just straight up left.
Like, he never came back.
(laughing)
And then I had to do the
whole shift on my own,
then doing all this shit and
I was like, I went to my boss
and I'm like, "So, yeah,
he didn't come back."
- He just went for a smoke break and--
- He just went for a smoke
break about two hours ago.
- Dude he just pulled like
the dad leaving for a smoke thing.
- Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
(laughing)
- He went to buy cigarettes
he never came back.
- He never came back and I was
like, "So what should I do?"
And they're like, "Oh, you're
just gonna work on your own."
And I'm like, "What?
What do you mean?
Like what do you mean?"
And this another time I was making,
it was the same guy actually,
it was the first hour of teaching him
and when you're--
- So what was the entire timeline?
How long did he work here
that you had to teach him for?
- Three hours and a half
and he went for smoke break.
(laughing)
But I had to keep working
because, and then I asked,
and this is really pretty bad,
I honestly, I could have fucking
sued McDonald's for this,
so when we were, this
really fucking hot oil,
it's like 400 degrees of ridiculous.
- Fry oil?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's ridiculously hot and
this asshole next to me,
I was like, "Yeah, just
gently put it in, you know?"
Next to me while showing him I'm like,
"So put the chicken nuggets in here."
And he fucking slams them in, right?
The oil went all over my hand, right?
- Yikes.
- And then I asked could I go
and put it on the cold water
to my boss and they were like,
"No, you gotta keep working."
And I'm like, "What?"
So I'm here fucking like crying in pain,
making these fucking burgers, right?
And then--
- And don't forget to smile.
- [Joey] Yeah, don't forget to smile.
- Right, "Don't forget to smile."
- I have a third degree burn.
- And so, about an hour later,
it's finally my time
to get a break, right?
And I'm eating my burger
and you can see my hand
is bright pink and like blistered.
And the other manager because of course,
there's multiple managers
in just one McDonald's.
The other manager comes
in and is mortified.
He's like, "What the fuck is that?"
He's like, "What happened?"
And I'm like, "Oh, I spilled oil on it."
And he's like, "Why didn't you
put your hand in the water?"
I was like, "Oh, because the
other manager said I couldn't."
And bear in mind I was
like 16, so yeah, you know,
I should have known that
I could have been like,
"No, fuck you, I'm putting
my hand in the water."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Again, when you're 16, if
the boss tells you to do-
- You do what you're told to do, right?
- You do what you do, right, of course.
- Yeah.
- And then he was mortified
and the other boss got in so much shit
and they apologized to me profusely.
And then they like were
like, "Yeah, it's okay,
you don't have to come to
work tomorrow, it's all paid."
And I was like, "Wow,
that's so nice of them."
But I realized at the time they were just
like hoping I wouldn't
fucking try and sue them
'cause I could have like--
- You could have easily.
- I should have honestly.
- Honestly, it's some serious H&S problem.
- Yeah, and then finally when I quit,
I quit prematurely
because I was just done.
My manager was a total bitch,
the store owner was
horrible, she hated dudes.
Like she would always
be so nice to the women
that are working there and, you know,
and whenever a guy did anything wrong,
she would absolutely like shit on you.
I know I'm talking so much sorry,
this is the last story I promise.
- I just can't get rid off
the fact that dude left off--
- Yeah, he fucking left.
- My mind was speed running McDonald's.
(laughing)
- It took me like eight months to realize,
what he realized in two hours, right?
Like that's what I would be glad--
- That seemed disrespectful
at that point, right?
It's just like all
right, this isn't for me.
- Right, right.
- I'ma head out, I'm out.
- He just walked out of McDonald's place.
- He was like, you know
what, the reduced money
on the meals is just
isn't worth it, right?
'Cause okay, you gotta admit, right?
I was the fucking king
when in school I was like,
"You on a lunch break?
I get half price off McDonald's
meals who wants to come?"
- I remember the cool
kids in school worked,
whoever worked at the coolest place
and could get like the best
discount, the discount,
so whoever works in the
fucking gaming store,
they were the king.
- Yeah, so I could be my
mate and in lunch I'm like,
"We can get a whole McDonald's
meal for two pounds,
wholemeal, any size you
want, treat yourself."
It was great, yeah, I
could have gotten fat.
So anyway, I'm working
like a shift, right?
And then I'd actually been
training to be a lifeguard,
I did all the stuff and I
applied to be a lifeguard
and, you know, when you work some place,
you put on a reference.
I never, have you ever had this
where they actually contact the reference?
- No.
- [Joey] No.
- I've never had that.
So I just thought it was like a myth.
I thought it was a bluff is like,
"Go on name someone, name someone."
- Fucking day to call me.
Name someone who we will
interrogate, I dare you.
So they actually fucking
called my McDonald's
whilst I was working my shift.
- Right.
- So they do it and they come in like,
"So Connor are you looking
for other employment?"
And I'm like, "Why, what do you mean?"
"Because we just got a
call from their council
asking for reference you to be a lifeguard
what's up with that, you didn't tell us."
And I was like, in my head I'm like,
"Why do I have to tell you?"
Like fuck you, you pay me $4 an hour,
like what do I owe you?
- Yeah, what are they gonna be,
like you can check out
but you can never leave.
- Yeah, and I was like, "Oh, well, yeah.
I mean, I was looking for a better job."
And they fucking like flipped a switch
when I said a better job.
They were like, "What do
you mean a better job?
You think McDonald's is a bad job?"
And I was like, "Well, mean--
- Yes.
- I'm looking around and I'm like, "Look."
- What surprised me is like
how little self awareness they seem
to have over there, right?
- 'Cause the thing is Garnt,
I don't wanna shit on some of these guys
'cause I know that I've met some managers
at McDonald's who are
genuinely like super nice guy,
they have such like, you know,
they understand like it's a McDonald's.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But the managers at my
McDonald's they were like,
"What are you trying to say mate?
You trying to say my
managerial job is like a joke?"
And in my head I'm kind of
like, "Yeah, yeah, kinda."
- Yes, actually.
- Did you see the food safety thing,
we had to fill out a line
that was a joke come on."
It's like, "Don't shit on the lettuce."
Obviously don't shit on the lettuce.
So the manager is really
pissed off, right?
The store owner is coming
in 10 minutes and he's like,
"I want you to talk to the
store and explain yourself
when he comes in."
I'm like, are you serious,
I'm 16, so.
- They really didn't not
wanna make you leave at all.
- They really like fucking put
me through the wringer dude
for $4 an hour dude like
can you believe that?
So my mom wondered why I
fucking hated working here
and she was like, "No, you're just
over exaggerating Connor?"
I'm like, "No, it was awful."
So the manager, the store
owner comes in, right?
And they made me go and talk
to her in front of customers.
And she's rinsing me in
front of these customers
like shouting at me in
front of these customers.
And I thought that was like weird.
And then I was like about
to cry and I'm like,
"You know what, I quit."
(laughing)
I quit.
- He said it, he said it.
- I'm going for a smoke break.
I'm gonna take my smoke break.
- My mom was so pissed off at me.
She was like you have like,
'cause I'd actually been
accepted for the other job.
I had to be home like
a month and a half left
before I start the
other job, she was like,
"I can't believe you
quit a month and a half
before your next job Connor
that's really like, what the fuck!"
And I was like, "Mom, you don't understand
how awful this was."
- It's McDonald's.
- Yeah, and like she
was just chewing me out
in front of these customers.
And like I was just like,
I'm not being paid enough to be humiliated
in front of these random people, right?
Like I don't, come on man.
Like I'm so fucking young.
- Did you smile the entire time?
- Yo, I was like,
I was just sitting down
like, "Okay, okay."
- Show a smile as you're
getting rinsed still, yeah.
- Yeah, and as she was
just doing it, I go,
"All right, you know
what, fuck it, I quit.
Like I quit, I'm done, I'm
done, I'm not doing this.
I'll finish this shift
but I'm done after this.
I'm not doing this."
- Yeah.
- I never heard from them again.
And then yeah, I went there
like three years later
after I'd like been killing it on YouTube
and then the manager, the one
who was a dick head was like,
"What are you doing now Connor?"
I'm like, "Well, I'm kinda--
- Oh, what did you want to know?
- Yeah, you know, I just got back from LA,
you know, I went to visit
my friends in Japan,
you know, I was just making, you know,
I work when I want make my own hours,
you know, it's great, you know?"
- You should have just been like,
"Oh, I eat at Burger
King pretty regularly."
(laughing)
- I just feel my tax rates is intense.
Damn, did you know that
tax rates is so high
when earn so much money.
Dude damn, that shit damn hurts man.
- Anyway I'm kinda moving forward.
(laughing)
- I mean, some of them were nice,
but, yeah, everyone was an asshole.
- Yeah, I mean, like
working in retail is like,
this isn't dissing anyone
who works in retail--
- But it is hard.
- As someone who has
worked in retail before,
you know, a lot of people in college
or in high school they get
the first job normally works
in retail and it's normally just to fuel
whatever hobby they have or, you know--
- Just look out for yourself man.
That's like this thing that I wish I did.
Like, I wish I like just didn't roll over
because I was very obedient as a kid
and I didn't really like,
I was always just taught
like whatever the elders
or you know, the person
in charge says just do it.
They know best, right?
I don't know what the fuck
I was doing at McDonald's.
Like what the fuck was I doing there?
I had no idea what I
was doing half the time,
I just did shit.
And I, dude, oh my God.
I used to spend like, when they were like,
"Go and get some fries
out of the freezer."
I used to spend like 10
minutes just sitting in there
'cause I was like, "Fuck,
dude, what am I doing, man?"
And it's so hot in the kitchen
that when you get to the
freezer they're like,
"Who's near the fries?"
"Me, me, me."
- You just had a fucking
existential crisis
just getting fries.
- The McDonald's freezers
has become like a panic room.
- Oh my God.
- I would literally just go
there for like five, 10 minutes
as long as I can get away
with it and just sit there
and be like, "Fuck, fuck!"
- Imagine if you open up a freezer
and there's like three
other employees in there.
It's like everyone is just
trying to get to the freezer.
- I was so jealous there was this one dude
in this whole job was
just moving the crates
into the like freezer and
that was his whole job
and I'm like, "I want that guy's job.
Fuck being in front of a deep fryer man."
That made my acne so bad.
- Oh, fuck yeah.
- I remember when I
was working at a Co-Op,
there would be all these
odd jobs I wish I could get.
Like there would be one guy's job was just
to fucking go outside and
collect all the trolleys
that people have taken to their cars.
- Oh my God, I want that.
- That's so nice because you just like,
you don't have to interact
with anybody, right?
- Yeah.
- That's the best job.
- 'Cause I was always on the table, right?
And my least favorite part of the job was
when anyone would like
try to make small talk.
I was like, "Look, I'm just
here to fucking stand here
and take your money, why are
you trying to talk to me?
I don't give a shit
about how your day is."
- Just talk to, beep, beep, nope.
- I got that smile talk as well
'cause like when they talk
to you, you gotta smile
and you gotta be having a good day
no matter what's going on.
And I just be like, I don't know, I would,
I didn't have like any bad
experiences with the customers,
but I mean, yeah, I had some
like fucking awful managers.
- What's up with those cashiers, right?
Where they would like take
fucking joy out of idying you.
What's up with that, you know what I mean?
Like if you just give your ID--
- I'm violating my power.
- It's like literally
like I'm being pulled over
by the cops and the ID
you for like a beer.
It's like, "ID please."
(police sirens wailing)
- 'Cause that moment in time,
they have all the power.
- Yeah, they look at the ID
like, "Hmm, nice address.
That's a nice area to live in."
(laughing)
- Like I hate that, like every time,
like 'cause in Australia, right?
Like whenever you go to a bar
or when you're going to the liquor store,
they have to ID like everybody
even if you clearly look like--
- You have to at least reached
age 25 I think is legal.
- I remember like, I went
to a bar with my dad once
and my dad got IDed.
And I remember he was
like, obviously the IDed me
'cause I was like 22
or whatever obviously,
but then guy looked at my dad
and was like, "ID please."
My dad straight up said,
"Are you fucking kidding me?
(laughing)
Do you know how many gray
hairs I have on my face.
Of course, I'm not fucking 20 years old."
And I think he was like,
"All right, fair enough."
(laughing)
I hate that though.
Like it's the movement of
looking down at your ID
and then just looking at you
with their eyes like this,
it's that movement, I'm like,
"What, is this fucking L.A Noire?
(laughing)
- I would hate the process
whenever I was working Co-Op
and I had to ask for ID
'cause I was 16 at the time as well.
(laughing)
For me, it just felt wrong
asking someone for ID
when I was obviously
like younger than them.
So anytime I'd have to
ask for ID there'd be like
most nervous stutter
like it would be like,
it would be like as if
like the power dynamic
is like the other way around.
So I'd be like, "Okay, can, can, can,
can I have, have, have your ID please?"
And honestly, like, if
they gave him their ID,
I'm just like, "Okay,
they probably over age."
(laughing)
- You didn't even check it, yeah?
Oh my God.
- I didn't have the
balls to ask my manager
to come check this man.
- Can you check this guy's ID please?
(laughing)
- If they've gone through the
trouble of getting the fake ID
just give it them the
fucking beer, why not.
- Yeah, no, it was like, remember
your 18th birthday though?
The first time you go to buy
like a fucking bottle of beer.
- I admittedly, I don't
remember my 18th birthday
for numerous reasons.
(laughing)
- I don't remember what I did,
but I do remember being like,
yeah, being able to finally buy a bottle.
- I remember that first
point or that first beer
as an adult and I was like,
it was like the biggest
fucking empowering power trip
that I've liked,
that I had felt in my 18
years of living until then.
- I was living life on the
edge before that, you know?
- Hey there boys and
girls, it's me, Mr. Titi.
Or whatever the hell like
hold myself last time.
Here to let you know that
this episode of Trash Taste
is sponsored by Guardian Tales.
Guardian Tales is a classic
action adventure RPG
with cute pixel graphics,
unique story with a different
theme for each chapter,
full of callbacks and
references to popular games,
books, movies and other pop culture.
Choose from more than 50 characters
and over 200 unique equipment
within 10 different equipment types.
And for those of you who
like gadget, characters
and equipment can be acquired
from loot box summons.
You can change up the
looks of your characters
with a variety of costumes
and complete characters
and equipment sets for bonuses.
So what are you waiting
for go get them all.
There are different modes
you can play in as well
as well as a single story
mode where you clear stages
with an entertaining
storyline by solving puzzles,
battling monsters and
finding hidden secrets.
In multiplayer modes you can play
the full player real time co-op raids
or real time one v one PvP.
In the challenging tell
mode you can face challenges
that can only be cleared
with specific weapons
and character types.
And there are four
different types of dungeons
to acquire guild
experience, evolution stones
and item enhancement materials.
There are also a bunch of
social and housing features
like the floating castle
where you can create
your own floating castle
to place buildings and structures
that generate wealth over time
and guild houses that can be customized
and you can walk around them in real time
with other guild members.
But if you pickup
Guardian Tales right now,
there's a brand new
update you can play called
the Raw Empire.
Pick up the new three Star
hero, Noble, succubus, Bianca,
and check out the new world
chapter nine Raw Empire
with five main stages, six
sub stages, one main quest
and six sub quests.
So if that sounds like something
that is interesting to you
then make sure to click the links down
in the description below to
check out the game for yourself.
I've been Mr. Titi and
thank you to Guardian Tales
for sponsoring today's episode.
Back to the video, wee.
- So anyway, let's move
on to the actual topic
of this episode.
- That was a very long tangent.
- Yeah, 50 minutes tale
only on Trash Taste.
- I've seen the sub-Reddit,
people are like,
"Just make a whole episode of tangents."
So, I don't know.
- That's kind of what
just happened, right?
We went from anime Cels to
McFlurries to McDonald's.
- One can argue like,
"What is even the tangent anymore, right?"
- I was going through my bag,
do you have stuff like
fucking papers in your bag
that just crushed down that you're like,
"What the fuck is in this shit?"
Then you finally like claw
it out and you're like,
"God, that's disgusting."
But I pulled one out and it
was like an Anime Expo pamphlet
from when I went to Anime Expo.
- Really?
- And I was like
(growling)
I miss Anime Expo so much.
- I missed anime conventions.
- So much man.
- I miss large crowds.
- I miss getting sick from all
the people fucking coughing
and sneezing on me.
- I never thought I'd miss Kahn flu.
(laughing)
- I just wanna be sneezed on
and don't worry about dying.
- Yeah, I just wanna handshake with like
the sweatiest weebs at the time.
- I wanna hug that's a little
too damn for my life in there
and just like, you
know, I miss it all man.
- I wanna to put my hand on a shoulder
and the shoulder is really
wet for some reason.
- I miss going into the gaming room
and just feeling like the
dampness of the atmosphere.
Like the fucking, I don't know what it is
about the gaming room and--
- 'Cause everyone is
sweating in there that's why.
- It's all the men from all
the players accumulating.
- It's all the game of you.
- Like the fucking room
needs its own weather report,
you know what I mean?
Like a humidity report.
- There's mushroom, cloudy.
- There's always mushrooms growing
in that room by the way.
- 92% humidity.
(laughing)
- Yeah, but let's talk
about the actual topic
of this episode, which is
funny or weird conventional.
- Just conventions period.
- Just conventions, just conventions.
- Because like I've been
seriously craving conventions.
- Honestly, I never thought
I would miss conventions.
- I need it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like I think I hit
a new low the other day guys
'cause being stuck in
the country, you know,
I'm very used to, you know, flying out
and going to conventions and stuff,
so like Casey Neistat video
started getting recommended
to me of like him sitting
in like First Class seats--
- Oh, I've watched them all.
- Yeah, and then I watched one
and then I watched the entire
series because I just missed
the feeling of being in an airplane,
so I'm just like, "God, I
wish that was me right now."
- I think Garnt is like
in his chair reclining.
Oh, gosh, it so uncomfortable, I miss it,
I miss it so much.
- And every time Sydney
comes in you be like,
"Oh, beef please."
(laughing)
Just creating your own turbulence.
It's like this is fun.
- Yeah, so--
- I remember, I think it was,
I don't remember whether
it was last episode
or the episode before, but
you were talking about like,
this is the longest period
I've ever been like,
that I've spent not being on a plane.
And so many comments on the
sub-Reddit are being like,
"Wow, that was the most
privileged Connor has ever said."
- Yeah, it's true, I did dig that.
(laughing)
- But it's true like--
- No, because, you know, even, you know,
I didn't come from a very
privileged background,
but it's just part of coming from
an international background,
I would say because,
I mean, you know, I'm full of
like, my full blood is Tai,
but I was raised in England.
So any chance we could get
to fly back home to Thailand,
we did and that was just part of my life.
You know, every year I'd
go back and visit grandma
and visit my family there.
- Of course, Sydney is
from America, right?
- Sydney is from America as well.
- America as well, yeah.
- Good privilege reflect Garnt.
(laughing)
- I'm not privileged, I'm blessed.
Yeah, but like, I don't know, like, just,
it made me miss, like this year,
which is the lack of conventions
because I thought at least
that like maybe there might be
like some smaller conventions
that we could go to hear.
Because in the back of my head
like just the other day, I was like--
- Is it same though in Japan?
Like I miss the kind of
scummy atmosphere in America--
- Oh, no, no, of course, but I
mean, like, yeah, I get that.
But I mean, I've been to a
few conventions in Japan,
it's still pretty
fucking fun because like,
just the other day in the
back of my head I was like,
"Well, I'm probably stuck
in Japan until what?
At least the end of April I think
the Japanese government said.
So in my head I was like,
"Oh, that means I can go to
winter Comic Con finally."
But then I was like, "Wait,
can I just like go away?"
(laughing)
I'm like, "Fuck!"
The one time I can go to winter Comic Con
and winter Comic Con it's not happening.
- Exactly.
- That fucking sucks, yeah.
- What about all the stories
I heard about Comic Con
is just basically it's you go
in and you buy the merchandise
or buy the Doujinshi or whatever
and then you leave, you know?
- That's what I heard, yeah.
- I mean, it's not like
the convention experience
that we have in America.
- Think of Anime Expo or any convention,
but the entire convention
is the artist alley
that's what Comic Con is.
It's just a stupid amount
of just tables and desks
where Doujin artists are
selling their Doujins
or other similar art.
- Honestly though,
honestly, I remember when, you know,
when you first go to conventions, right?
I remember like the first
conventions you go to
I tried to go to every panel,
I have a fucking full on
schedule where I'm gonna be like,
"Okay, this is the time
going to the panel,
this is the time I'm gonna
hit like the artists alley,
this is gonna be the
time where hit up like
the convention floor and everything."
And now you go to enough conventions
and you're just like whatever man.
- And then your occupation is just like,
"Let's go to Chick-fil-A."
(laughing)
- I've never been to a
panel that isn't my friends
or my own.
- Yeah , me neither.
- I've never liked just
seen a panel and be like,
"That looks fun, I'll go."
Like I just don't like I'd rather eat.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Eating is great, but--
- I probably go hang out with people.
- Now my favorite place to
go in the actual convention
is probably the artist alley
because the artist alley,
when I first started going was the place
that I never hit up.
And then now you go to enough conventions,
and you live in Japan as
well, and you go to like the,
the main hall and most
of the stuff you can find
in the main hallways is like synonymous
across all conventions, but
I feel like artists alley
is where you find all
the actual cool shit.
- That's the thing, right?
It's like the only,
usually with conventions
the only thing about a
convention a lot of the times
that's completely different
to any other convention
is the artist alley
because you'll always find
some fucking artists or
whatever where you say,
"Oh shit, I've never seen that before."
Because you go down like
to the regular thing
and as you said, it's like,
"Oh, I could just fucking buy this Oikawa
for like a third of the price,
so it's just like what's the point?
- And the thing is especially
being with Trash Taste,
I've realized how limited my wardrobe is,
like cycling through
all the T-shirts I have
because most of the time,
every time I go to an anime convention,
I buy like two or three
T-shirts from the artists alley.
So just just because I haven't gone
to any convention this year,
I haven't been able to
recycle any of my new clothes
or anything like that.
- I saw a comment that
was like, "Oh my God,
Connor is wearing the
same shirt that he wore
in episode like two."
And it's like Episode 19 I'm like,
"How many fucking shirts do you own?
Do you expect me to throw
them away when I'm done?
- I still haven't worn the same shirt yet.
- What?
- Because now that it's getting cold,
I can finally bust out my long sleeves.
So I'm like, "Thank God I was about
to run out of my short sleeved T-shirts.
- I wore one shirt like a lot recently
and I got a fucking comment that was like,
"Why are you always wearing that shirt?"
I'm like, "You never heard
of a fucking laundry machine
or washing machine, like what
the fuck, what do you mean?
Like why am I always
wearing the same shirt?"
- It's like what do you wear a shirt once
then you throw it away?
- Like you don't wash
your shirts, I'm confused,
why is this weird, I don't understand.
- Yeah, but I mean, like
that's all they see, right?
- True, true, true.
- A week span on Trash Taste might as well
just be a day to them.
- It's made me self conscious about
just how many clothes
I have in my wardrobe
and how many shirts I can get away with
without recycling the
same thing too many times
that people can notice, but--
- Yeah, especially with you
because you very rarely,
like actually make a physical appearance
in your videos, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- So you don't have to care about it.
- Normally, I don't care about this shit.
Normally, I'm just a
fucking disembodied voice.
- I mean, who knows,
Garnt might be butt naked
when he's filming the
audio form you never know.
(laughing)
- I'd like to hope so anyway,
anyway back to convention.
- Yes, this ends with by the way.
(laughing)
Back to conventions.
All right. I mean, fuck, what should we,
we should talk about
questions, funny stories.
- I mean, like just, I
guess, memorable story.
It doesn't necessarily have to be funny,
but just like some memorable stories.
- Would like a convention survival guide.
- I mean we could do that.
- Sure, sure.
- I'm sure we'll keep
working up stories that way.
- I don't know, I feel like, you know,
here's the real privilege lads,
I have never, I've only
gone to like one convention
like not as like a guest or like,
before I was a YouTuber essentially.
So I feel like my experience
of Connor is like,
vastly different from other people's like,
'cause like I feel like as
an attendee AX is like--
(laughing)
- Here he goes, here he goes.
- I guess, okay, when you hear the lines
are like five hours to get in,
and I mean, let's be honest,
we can apply for the badge
that just lets us like walk in, right?
We can just walk right in.
- Or we can just jump right into it.
- Yeah, we can jump right into the pit.
- I'm not gonna lie,
if you told me I had a line
of five hours to get to AX,
I'd be like, "Nah, I'm going home."
- Yeah.
- I'm going home.
- What I don't understand
about some people in AX
is the people who are
willingly waiting three hours
to get to a panel.
- Oh, fuck that.
- Oh, like a premiere
or something like that.
And I'm just thinking,
you know, I like anime,
but that shit is gonna be
on Crunchyroll like a month.
I can wait a month, you know what I mean?
I don't need to be at the
premiere, unless it's like,
you know, I get a pass or something.
- What was it the My Hero
Academia movie last year
or the year before had like a
four hour line or something?
- Yeah.
- Something ridiculous
like that, I'm like,
"Guys, it's gonna it's
gonna be on Crunchyroll
in like two weeks.
- The only reason I watched
the Promare movie was
because someone from GKIDS
and Trigger got me in.
I was like, I'm not queuing four hours.
Are you kidding me, no, way."
I don't care you could be like
the second coming of Christ
and I'll be like, "Five hour
long, nah, get outta here man."
- Do you know how many Chick-fil-A's
I can get in that time?
(laughing)
- Do you know how many beers
I can drink in five hours?
Like come on, man.
- Yeah.
- I gotta have a good time and five hours.
- You could just go down
to the fucking bar or park,
which is what I spend most my
time doing now at conventions.
Just like talking to different people
and catching up with different people
'cause that to me is the real
conventionalizing experience.
There's the convention itself,
but after I'd say about
two conventions I was like,
"I just rather just talk to people
or I just talk to other animators
rather than going to the
actual convention itself.
- Do you ever try and get
people in to staff with you
if they don't have like the badge?
- Oh yeah, all the time.
- Yeah, yeah, I love like
seeing like right, bullshit,
all right, he rides with me, he's with me.
He just got back pass.
- Like VIP access.
Yeah, you with me.
- You wanna like--
- He's like, "My friend and
what's your name again?"
- John.
- Yeah, John.
(laughing)
- "I thought you were like four friends?"
You're like, fuck here
we go I got Trump balls,
"Yeah, they're all part of the Japanese--
- Yeah, security guards.
- Yeah, you like think of
some bullshit on the thing
and then like-
- I have four managers.
- You gotta hope, like I think the problem
is with some conventions
like AX that problem is,
not my problem good thing for me,
they've so many volunteers,
the volunteers don't know shit.
So you can just bullshit to them like,
"You're in line, you're
with me, it's cool, cool.
Get her in, get her in."
- Yeah, if anything at Anime Expo,
I've found that there's
always at least one volunteer
who knows who I am.
- Yeah, they'll let you in.
- They just let me in.
They're like, "Oh, Anime Man I follow you,
come in bro, come in.
Oh, yeah, you have five
other people behind you,
come in fuck it, you're probably
friends with them, right?
- And they'll ask you to take a picture
and while you're like
smuggling your friend in.
(laughing)
I feel bad, you know, okay.
- But I think one thing to
like nail down is the
difference between Anime Expo
and basically every other convention.
- Yeah.
- I feel like Anime Expo
exists in its own bubble.
And I think like everyone
should experience Anime Expo
for like once 'cause it's,
it's kinda like not even a
convention at this point,
it's kinda like a convention
and a business expo
all at once, you know what I mean?
So you kinda get a
little bit of everything
and a little bit of nothing as well
because if you don't
plan yourself correctly,
then you just end up experiencing lines.
- It's a cluster fuck in every
sense of the worst, right?
- Especially for like
some people who are like,
"Yeah, this is AX, good
I'm planning to go alone."
I'm like, "Do not go to AX alone."
I was like--
- Define good?
- I'm like, "You could
probably go to Comic Con alone
and probably make something out of it,
but in AX everyone already
has that group with them,
so it's like--
- It's like you don't have
enough time to hang out
with the group that you have already,
let alone hanging out
with like random ones,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
Fuck, I just had like so many flashbacks
of who I was hanging
out with random people
that went terribly wrong.
'Cause okay, you've all been there, right?
Everyone goes to convention, right?
- Yeah.
- You know, you've gotta decide,
I really wanna go to this convention,
but fuck hotel rooms are expensive,
so it's like how many people
can I fit in this hotel room
to reduce it to a point
where I'm comfortable, right?
And we said this on my podcast where like,
if you're in charge the booking,
you get dibs on the bed, right?
So that's why I used to be
in charge of the bookings,
I'm like, "I'm getting the
bed, I'm getting the best bed.
I'm getting the key."
- All you guys are getting the floor.
- 'Cause oh my God, if
the hotel doesn't ask you
how many keys you want,
it's like there's two
keys between six of you.
And it's like how do we--
- How do we distribute?
- How do we decide who gets a key?
Like I book it, I book it.
- The person with the key has the power.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Because you can come and go as you want,
because there's nothing
worse than just sitting there
with all your bags being
like calling up your mate,
not fucking picking up and you're,
"I wanna go back to the hotel
room answer me you cunt."
- Like mobile service in the
conventional it's fucking--
- Oh my God, awful.
- It's non existent.
- Yeah.
- You just basically gotta
pretend you're back into like
the fucking 18th century.
Like how do I contact Joey,
especially when you're in America,
we don't have American phones either.
Like I have a contract on my British phone
that gives me American
service which is usable
in most places, but in like a convention,
you are getting like zero fucking service.
- It's like a fucking
Greek marathon, right?
You have to ask someone
to like can you run
to the outside of the convention
and tell Joey that I'm here.
It's like, "All right, I'll see you soon."
- Have you ever stayed in a room
with people who you're like,
"Fuck, I regret staying
in a room with them."
- Yes.
- Yeah, I'm not gonna name names.
- Can I name your name, all right fuck!
- I can't name my names,
but I mean, you stayed with
some Discord people, right?
- Yeah, started with a
bunch of people on Discord
and that was fucking nightmare.
- That sounds like a nightmare.
- It was fucking, I was like
the pseudo leader of the group.
- Right.
- And there's just so
many fucking problems
and this is also when
I just started YouTube
and I hadn't formally met, I met you,
no, I met Sydney, I didn't get to see you,
but we were gonna hang
out we had planned to
and I hadn't met you yet, had I?
- I don't think so.
- So, this was kinda like,
I don't know how I was
like gonna make mates.
You know, I was planning
to hang out with you guys
for the majority of it.
- Oh, was this the first AX then?
- The first AX I went to.
- You spend most of your time with us.
- Yeah.
- I remember that.
- So I told the people
I was staying with like,
"Hey, this is like straight
up just like a room thing.
I'm gonna be hanging out with other people
like for like 99% of this."
Told them that like many times.
I think like one of them
didn't quite get the memo
and he was like really hoping
that I would introduce him
to like everyone and be like,
"Yo, he's my best mate, he's heeeey."
And the more nos, he was a fucking creep.
So like, I didn't even
wanna hang out with him.
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And it wasn't like, at
first he was a little strange,
you know, he was an American
and he was like a military dude.
And in my experience
military dudes are like 50/50
on whether they're like totally chilled
or fucking psychotic.
- I actually totally agree.
I've met so many military dudes
and there is no in between.
- There's no in between.
- Either they're a fucking psycho
or they're the most chillest
dude you can ever imagine.
- Everywhere I've met
it's always like that.
It's like they're no chill.
- Yeah.
- So he's like kinda nice,
you know, he's a little weird.
And like one time I remember
I met you at a party
and then like he was
texting me the whole time
and I think I mentioned where
and I was actually leaving this party.
Do you remember this?
- Yeah, I remember this.
- We go outside and he's
waiting there at like 1:00 a.m.,
he's like, "Hey, Connor how
are you doing man, can I join?"
And we're like getting
an Uber and I'm like,
"No, man, we gotta Uber somewhere else.
I'm really sorry, man."
'Cause it's like how do you introduce,
it's like kinda creepy 'cause
everyone has already seen
that he's waiting outside, it's
really creepy and it like--
- It's the over enthusiasm, right?
- 'Cause the thing about anime conventions
that's so difficult for a lot of people
to like wrap their heads
around is just like,
what is socially accepted,
you know what I mean?
- Social rules are thrown
out the window definitely.
- When you don't know someone,
I think it's like a social rule
when you shouldn't be
bringing your friends in,
unless you have like a reason to.
But if you don't, like okay,
if you bring someone into a friend group
and that guy is an asshole
or a creep that's on me.
- That's on you.
- That's on me.
I brought him in.
- Yeah.
- And I didn't know him
and I got kind of signs
that he was a creep.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I didn't wanna bring
him in 'cause I was like,
if I bring him to this party
and he starts like fucking
chatting up Gigguk all night
like, "Hey, man, I love your
videos can we take a pic
and can I smell your penis?"
Like, you know what I mean?
It's like kinda looks terrible
on me, so I was like nah.
- And the party was at my house or-
- Your Airbnb and there's like 10 of us,
so it's really intimate.
So I told him I was like, "Listen, man,
I'm really sorry dude, but I
don't really know like Garnt
or anyone in this group pretty
well, I would invite you,
I just don't feel comfortable doing it.
I explained to him and
he was so pissed off.
- He was pissed off?
- He was so pissed off.
So then I came back at like
5:00 a.m. to my shitty hotel
and like, it's the suburbs
of LA and like it was--
- It was like the Korea town, wasn't it?
- No, it's further away.
It's like, even like further
out, it was really far out
and it was really sketchy, it was like a,
what is it called, it
wasn't even like a holiday,
it was one of the even
the more budget chains.
It was bad, it was really bad.
And at this hotel for
some reason at midnight
all the cards reset.
So if you came back after midnight,
you'd go to the front desk.
But the front desk wasn't open.
- All right, right.
- So if you came back after midnight,
you'd hope someone else
is already in the room
or just wait out your door till 6:00 a.m.
till someone comes.
- What?
- Yeah, it's stupid.
So he was in the room
and he'd been like
drinking alone in his room
and I felt really bad, but so I'm like,
"Hey, man, let me in, let me in."
Whatever, you know, it's
like 5:00 a.m. like,
"Dude I really wanna fucking sleep."
So he opens the door and
comes out block, oh shit,
blocking the door so I couldn't get in.
- Right.
- I'm like, "Yo, what the
fuck man like, let me in.
I wanna sleep it's 5:00 a.m.
and he's like absolutely hammered.
He's like, "Listen Connor,
I saw your call man.
(laughing)
Why didn't let me in the party?"
I'm like, "Dude I'm so sorry
but not now man it's 5:00 a.m.
let me sleep."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- We can talk about in the morning.
Dude, please let me
sleep and then whatever.
So then we slept whatever
finally he let me in,
but I thought it's weird that he was like,
I was ignoring him, I'm
trying to open the door,
he's blocking me and I'm
like, "What the fuck man?
Let me in, it's fine man,
I paid for this room let me sleep."
And like near the end one of
the other peoples in my room,
who was like a lot smaller and like,
I guess he thought they were cute
and then they called me up and he's like,
"Hey, he just tried to
pay me to suck his dick."
And I'm like, "What the fuck!"
What the fuck!
I'm like, "What is happening
in this hotel room?"
- What?
- Yikes.
- And then I was like,
"I'm so fucking glad
I didn't introduce you
to any of my friends if you
turn around asking people
to suck your dick for
money are you kidding me?"
So, needless to say I went to
the hotel room just explained
to him like, "Hey, what the fuck man?
Don't do that you asshole?
Like this is my friend don't
make them uncomfortable."
And then he didn't do anything
and he went stayed somewhere
else like the last night
'cause I was like,
"Dude, don't stay in this room with them."
And so, I've never stayed with
any random people on Discord
that I've never met before ever again.
- I've heard so many horror
stories from Discord.
I don't know what it is about Discord.
And I'm gonna call it
like the Discord hotel.
Those never ever go right.
Like I've, 'cause even
like the best you can do
is have like a little bit of drama,
but there's never zero drama.
Nobody ever comes out
there with just like,
"Yeah, everyone was just chilled,
we had the most chillest time,
everyone was understanding,
you know what I'm saying?"
- What is about everything
that's planned on Discord
just ends up horrible?
(laughing)
What is it about?
- Because you can't like really
know who's weird on Discord.
Like the problem is,
is that you don't really
know how weird people are
until you meet them.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Exactly.
You also, it's doubly
true on Discord as well
where you're here for this like,
you're here for this
server, which is like solely
where you talk about this one,
you know, common interests or whatever
and you you rarely talk
about your own personality--
- I just don't understand
the mentality though of like,
looking at a Discord group and being like,
"Okay, there's three other people in here,
never seen their faces--
- I didn't care 'cause I--
- Never met them before,
I'm gonna stay in a room with
them over night, it's like--
- 'Cause I was broke Joey
what do you want from me?
(laughing)
- Like at least like, you know,
hang out with them outside.
- I understand to all the
conventioner out there
who've done the same thing as me
'cause you're broke as fuck!
Like you gotta do what you gotta do.
And plus, I knew I could
take care of myself.
Like I don't have time,
like I didn't worry, but I,
you know, if I hear like 18
year old girls that do it
and I'm like, whoa, with dudes, I'm whoa.
- I mean that's just
calling for a disaster.
- I mean, like it's a
recipe for disaster, right?
Because I've only stayed in,
I've only gone to conventions
after I had like a full time job.
- Right, right.
- So even if it wasn't
like a great paying job
at least I could just
afford my own hotel room
and stuff like that or like
just a really cheap motel room,
you know what I mean?
But if I had gotten before
I was like say 21, 22
when I was just a broke uni
student or just God, forbid,
like before even uni,
I can imagine so many horrible situations
that could have arose of this.
- Right, right.
- Which kinda like there's no
real way to protect yourself
around that especially
if you're just roaming
with random people on Discord,
which is such a coin flip, you know?
- Yeah, yes.
- And I would argue like,
is the anime con really that worth it?
- Yeah, it is.
- Honestly?
- Honestly, you know
what, all that weird shit
that happened to side that I
don't think I told you guys
that whatever, but, yeah, I
mean, all of that weird shit
the side that I had to deal with,
I'll fucking do it again easy.
(laughing)
- But you'll fucking do anything.
- I mean, that was fun.
I mean, like the convention was fun.
That was a nuisance, but, you know,
I mean, it's nice exercise
knowing that I can tell someone
to fuck off, you know?
I don't know, what, I
mean, it is what it is.
I knew that when I did
that there was a chance
that it could go horribly wrong.
And it did go horribly wrong
and I learned my lesson,
but I'm not doing that again.
(laughing)
- But you said you would
if you have the chance?
- No, I mean, I said I
understand if, you know,
when you're like 18,
you got like 200 bucks max to your name.
The fare ticket is 50
bucks, you've gotta get
that hotel room down to 100 bucks somehow.
It doesn't matter how many
people are gonna go in that room.
- You gotta divide the room
with the amount of bodies
that will fit in it, you know what I mean?
If you need to sleep on the
floor, you sleep on the floor.
People who sleep on the
bed they pay a premium.
- Most of the time.
- Mostly it's like a fucking
human trafficking lodge.
- Have you ever been to a
fucking convention room Joey?
Jesus Christ, like a fucking
bomb could go off in there,
it would be less messy.
Just like the amount of like,
I mean, if you've got
a cos player in there,
say goodbye to floor space,
say goodbye to fucking floor space.
- The same reason they are allergic
to closing their fucking suitcase
'cause it has to be wide
open the whole fucking time,
can't close it, okay, fine.
Yeah, I don't know, I mean, it's whatever.
You should try it some time.
- No, thank you, I can
afford my own hotel room.
(laughing)
I good dude.
- For the frills, do you
fucking roll that dice
or do you just roll with it?
Who knows what story you'll get.
- You gonna get through somehow, right?
- Yeah, okay, I don't know.
I like I know this sounds like super,
I guess it sounds weird or
dangerous to some people,
I love just meeting new
people in that kind of way.
- I mean, look I don't mind
meeting new people either, but--
- I don't mind meeting a new
person for the first time
in my hotel room.
- Yeah, I don't wanna pull a gotcha role
where I might end up, you know,
sleeping with a fucking
murderer, you know?
- I don't mind, I'll take that odd.
You might get the fucking
coolest friend for life
by doing that, you know what I mean?
- There's other ways to meet
cool friends for life man.
- But you get that fucking story
of we met at anime convention, right?
- That's what I'm saying.
You'll do anything to content.
- I love a-
- Spoken like a true YouTuber.
- I just know, I don't even
think of it as content,
I just love like the idea
of like making a friend
through such a weird
and unconventional way
where I feel like it makes
such a good friendship,
I don't know.
- I get that, but that's
another coin for me.
- I feel like I'm somewhere
in the middle of both of you
'cause I do like meeting new people
and everything like that.
I used to be that guy who
was just like up for anything
and be like, "Yeah,
I'll go meet Donald like
in a dark alleyway whatever."
But like, I've had like enough
bad experiences to be like,
you know what, maybe I'll do
like a just a little bit of
a background check before I
jump right into it, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, oh my God, yeah.
Met several people on
Discord who turned out
to be really sketchy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I just gotta, there's
a lot of dudes on Discord
who like underage girls
and you just gotta call that shit out
when you see any signs of it, man.
- Yeah, I feel like a lot of,
especially in anime conventions,
a lot of people especially
obviously like anime,
you know, anime fans and
weebs and everything,
they don't have the
confidence to confront people
when they see some shit happening.
So I feel like with a
lot of convention stories
that I've heard, it's it's
mostly bogged down to people,
just people just didn't know
how to handle the situation
'cause they've never seen
it happen in front of them.
And so the first time you experienced it,
you just kinda just freeze up to be like,
what is this happening
now, is this happening now?
You know what I mean?
And no matter what you tell yourself,
you're going to do at that moment,
you're totally unprepared for that moment.
So I would say like, the
best advice I could give is,
if you see anything bad happening,
like don't let that shit lie, call it out.
- Also, especially if
they're your friends.
Like I know a lot of people
who are like it's hard to like,
you know, call out your
friend and be like,
"Dude, what the fuck!"
You gotta call that shit out.
It's like if you let it slide,
they'll just keep doing it.
- A good friend will call.
- We gotta stop this shit out of community
because we saw what happened
to this slash community, right?
And I don't know what's
happened behind the scene
of the anime community.
- Oh, yeah, I don't wanna imagine.
- I don't wanna imagine it
because I wasn't part of the community
when some of the worst stories
that happened behind the scenes.
- I mean, yeah, we'd
like to see a YouTuber
that I used to do stuff with
and I've had people on Discord
who I considered friends
who later on found out
that they'd like did
some fucking horrible stuff.
And like, honestly, there
were like, you know,
there were signs and I just ignored it
'cause I was like, "Oh, well,
I mean, I think, you know,
they're just quirky, they're
not gonna hurt anyone."
You just gotta call that shit out
when you see it unfortunately.
So even if it's your friend,
please call them out,
and bring them out.
- Especially if it's a friend, you know,
only through the internet
'cause, you know, we,
I mean, we all met through
the internet, right?
But I mean, we've also met in real life
and we've hang out so many times
before I've really knew
your guys' real personality
and everything like that, right?
So if it's some guy or some
girl you've met through
the internet, especially if
it's Discord or something
and you've only talked to
them through the internet,
meeting friends, making
friends on the internet
is completely fine,
but understand that
that's totally different
from being at friend Irl.
And until you've hang out Irl a few times,
you really can't have a true
grasp of their personality
and what they might be like.
- And that's why it's
always such a gamble, right?
Like when you meet,
again, like when you meet
that person on Discord
and then you be like,
"All right, let's go to
a convention together."
And you'll be hanging out
with a completely different person.
You know, this is like,
"Oh, you weren't like this
when we were chatting on
Discord what the fuck!"
And I've had a lot of
experiences like that
where I would be talking to someone online
and then I'd be like,
"Oh, you're going to AX,
oh, I'm going to AX as well,
let's meet up and hang out.
And then I talked to them I'm like, "Wow!"
(laughing)
- You aren't what I expected at all?
- Yeah, you are not the same
person I texted two days ago."
Yeah.
- Man, fuck!
- For better or worse, right?
Sometimes they're way cooler in real life,
sometimes they're just
like, oof in real life.
- And there's so many
social norms that you,
(laughing)
I don't know why, I get like--
- Tell the all of the
dumb shit that's happened.
- Common sense just doesn't
seem to like make sense.
Like common sense just isn't common
in anime conventions, right?
Especially when it comes to
like meeting people and stuff
'cause you talked about, you know,
the introducing the one friend
to like your friend group or something.
What will happen if you're like,
you're going to this party, right?
And you can be like, okay,
you can bring like this one friends
that you might wanna
kinda wanna introduce,
but they're with a group
of like five, six people.
And they're like,
"Can you like get all
these people in as well?"
And you're like, "Ugh!"
- What is it about these
people who are like,
"Oh, plus one, also plus
one group of friends, right?
That's what it means,
yeah, all right, cool.
I got like seven people back there."
- Yeah, it's hard 'cause
obviously I don't wanna be like,
yeah, you know, only
one person can come in,
but I also gonna have the
balls to do something like,
I'd be like, "All right mates,
I've got a sick invitation from a guy,
I'm gonna go to that, I
hope you'll understand."
Like that's what I would do.
I'll be like, "Hey, man,
I got an opportunity
that I don't really get come
across often, can I take it?
Please, don't be mad at me."
- Yeah, yeah, I think
it's just understanding
that it's a convention.
People, you know, you're
not always gonna hang out
with the same friend group all the time,
so I feel like if you,
if you have like some other
people you wanna meet,
then I feel like you just let them go.
Don't feel betrayed by
your friend hang out
with other people whatever.
- This video is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- You can use ExpressVPN
to unlock shows and movies
that are only available
in other countries.
- For example, I used
ExpressVPN the other day
because Netflix Japan doesn't have any
of the Harry Potter movies.
So--
- Okay.
- Yeah, weirdly enough
and I wanted to watch some Harry Potter,
so I flicked on ExpressVPN,
set it to the UK as you do
and boom, all of the Harry Potter movies.
- Netflix Japan doesn't
have English subtitles
or anime sometimes, so I
have to go actually, no joke,
to the VPN to be in the UK,
so I can watch the anime
that's in Japan with
the English subtitles.
Thank you Netflix.
- I don't have that problem,
but thank you Netflix.
- Fuck you Joey.
- I personally use ExpressVPN
to watch some BBC shows
on like BBC i Player and
stuff you can only get
in the UK as well.
- [Connor] ExpressVPN let's
you change your online location
so you can control
where you want the sites
to think you're located.
- [Garnt] Open the app, select a location,
tap one button to connect
and refresh the page
to access 1000s of new shows and movies.
- [Joey] You can also choose from
almost 100 different countries
and this works with any
streaming service Hulu, BBC,
i Player, YouTube, you name it.
- Yeah, you can watch Studio
Ghibli films on UK Netflix,
which I'm definitely not gonna do
'cause I'm ain't sleeping yet.
- You can stream in HD, no
problem ,no buffering and no lag.
I can legit confess to
that, I've used it a lot
and, yeah, it's great.
- [Joey] It's also compatible
with all your devices,
phones, laptops, media
consoles, smart TVs and more.
- [Garnt] Not only does it
let you change your location,
but encrypts all your data as well
and lets you surf the web anonymously.
- I actually watch hentai, I'm okay.
A lot of them are banned
in Japan, I'm just saying.
Go to expressvpn.com/trashtaste
to get an extra three months
of ExpressVPN for free gentlemen.
- That's expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
Links down in description below.
- Thank you so much ExpressVPN,
back to the video.
Speaking of inappropriate,
like the most inappropriate
thing happened to me
at a UK convention surprisingly.
- Oh, okay.
- I think I've told this
story like a million times,
but fuck it we'll say it here again.
It's the one where like,
all right, I think I should
tell the story as it happened.
In order, naturally.
So I'm just finished with a panel, right?
You know, killed it,
answered all these questions like a boss,
I haven't heard that phrase in a while.
- Wow, was this 2004?
- Yeah, right.
So and then when you're done
with the panel, you know,
I'm like, all right, I'll
take pictures outside,
you know, in the line.
So I'm taking pitches and
the first one comes up,
first girl, she's like 14, 13.
And I'm taking a picture
and she's like smiling like,
"Hey, by the way, can I grab your ass?"
And I'm like--
- Oh, this one?
- Yeah, I'm like, I'm like, "What?
What do you mean?
Do you know what you
just said little girl?"
And she was like, I was
like, "No, I think, no, no.
Why would you ask that?
Yeah, well, okay, whatever."
So and then, you know, next picture, fine,
next picture fine and as I'm
taking this next picture,
I feel this like grip, like
a tightening on my ass,
but like, and its getting--
- Alien space.
- This grip, this grip,
gets like fucking iron clad
on my ass and then I'm like
turning around I was like,
"Hey, what the fuck!"
And then I said, oh,
because I turned around
and she's just like, like this.
(laughing)
And I'm like what are
you doing in my head.
I'm like, ah, 'cause I'm like,
"How the fuck do I react to this?"
I don't wanna swat her away like a fly.
- Yeah, begone.
- Don't.
(laughing)
And so I was like, what the?
So she grabbed it and
then when I turned around,
she fucking ran off.
I was like, "What the fuck!"
And I'm looking at the
guy who's helping me out
and I'm like "Yo, what the fuck was that?"
He's like, "What the fuck!"
And he went to look after, like, go after,
and to like toddle her off, but she went.
- How many years ago was this?
- It's like three or four.
- Is this like MCMs?
- No, this is like a
really small London one,
the tiny one.
- 'Cause like a similar
thing happened to me at,
it was some of the, one
of the early MCMs, okay?
- Right, right.
- And I was, so I was having a meetup.
And it was like,
it was like one of one
of my very first meetups
and it was just as I like,
just after I started dating Syd,
so it was like Sydney's first
UK anime convention as well.
And so I was having this meetup
and we were taking
pictures and everything.
And then this girl comes take a picture
and you can immediately
you can immediately tell
that she was not respecting
my personal boundaries,
she was very, very touchy feely--
- They're the worst.
- Yeah, and Sydney is
like raised her eyes,
lasered in on it immediately, right?
Immediately, I could feel
like the death Claire
on this girl without having
to look at Sydney, right?
- Like in the middle of the fucking
like Harry Potter Voldemort
like, "You wanna battle?"
(laughing)
- So I know that Sydney
is watching everything
and she's like being really
touchy feely and I'm just like,
I'm trying to just be like,
"Okay, you know, I have
my personal boundaries.
I'll take a picture and everything."
And so, we go in for the picture
and she like goes on
for like a full on hug.
It's like, I'm just there being like, hey,
and she just grabs me like
that and just hugs me.
And then I didn't need to
see where Sydney's face was,
but I could feel it, I could feel it.
(laughing)
And then afterwards I'm like,
"Oh, yeah, thank you for
coming to my meetup."
And she goes in for a fucking kiss
and I had to like turn my cheek.
And I turn my cheek in time,
but she goes for my mouth
and then I turns--
- She goes for your mouth?
- Yeah, and she hits my cheek.
And then I just hear Sydney,
like I've never heard Sydney
make this noise ever again,
but she fucking hissed.
(laughing)
- She's a fucking snake.
- Yeah, she's like, "Ssssss!"
- What does it do?
- I don't know and then
same, same as your girl,
she just fucking runs off
before I could say anything.
And I'm just like, "What just happened?
What am I supposed to
do in this situation?"
- You know what the worse part was,
when I got home that day,
I go on fucking Twitter
and she replied to my tweet being like,
"Hi, I'm the girl who grabbed
your ass, it felt good."
And I was like, "First of all, thank you.
Second of all, what the fuck!
What the fuck!"
I was like, you know that's,
I reply, like be like,
"Dude, that was super
fucking inappropriate.
You shouldn't do that."
And she was like, "Oh, I didn't realize."
I'm like--
- I didn't realize?
- What the fuck you didn't realize, what?
- Like what kind of
family were you raised in
where it's like, oh, yes, hello, sir?
- What are you really doing
like fucking measuring your
foam every fucking day?
Why are you--
- Which year was this?
- Oh shit, this must have
been like 2000, fuck, 16, 17.
- That's the thing, right?
It's like, I feel like
'cause I have a similar story
that happened around that time.
- You do?
- Yeah.
- What the fuck!
- Yeah, well, my mine was in about 2016.
- We all fucking survived
something here, God damn.
- Mine was around like 2017, it was at AX.
And this is, I had just like,
started going out with Aki,
but this is before we went public.
So this is like the
convention that I met Aki
and that was like two days,
like literally two days
after we decided like, "Okay,
let's start going out."
And we were doing a signing together.
This fucking girl comes up to
me and she's dressed in like,
I think it was like Monica
Michael* or something,
but she had like a giant wand, right?
Like a massive like stuff
and she puts it down
and she's like, "Hi, Joey."
And I'm like, "Oh, no, it's
one of these kinds of girls."
All right, "Hey, what's up?"
And she's like, "Can you sign the stuff?"
I'm like, "Yeah, sure."
I start signing it and then she's like,
"Also here's a question but
can I be an Anime Expo Waifu?"
And I just kind of stopped and--
- How to trigger a flight
of anime, Jesus Christ!
- And the moment she said that,
I just kind of stopped
and looked up I was like,
"Could you say that again please?"
'Cause in my head I'm starting to panic
and same with Sydney, right?
I could feel the fucking
glare of Aki right
on my fucking neck.
Like I didn't even have to look over,
like I know you're staring at me.
And of course right, I
have the pressure from here
and the pressure right
in front of me, right?
There's two women staring at me
for totally different reasons.
And I just fucking panic, all right?
I couldn't like, 'cause
at that point I was like,
I couldn't say like yeah sure jokingly
because my woman is fucking glaring at me.
- The no right answer in that situation.
- But I also couldn't say no right
because I don't wanna hurt her feelings
and she lined up, you know,
all this time to like meet me.
And so I just fucking panicked
and I said I don't know I got ranks.
(laughing)
- Oh my God, Joey.
You didn't have to murder her like that.
(laughing)
- I got ranks.
And then she replied back being like,
"Then can I come to the
top of the ranking?"
And then I said--
- Girl you gotta learn to give up, man.
- Yeah, and I was like,
"Ah, I don't know, man.
Like it takes time.
I was just bullshitting this entire time
and the moment she's like,
"Oh, okay no worries."
Again, tried to go in for a kiss
and I just fucking like dogged that shit,
so she only got me on the
chick and then she walked off.
And then Aki under her breath was like,
"What did you mean by ranks?"
(laughing)
I was like I'm sorry, I paniced.
What are you supposed to
say in that situation?
- There is no right answer, but--
- There was no right answer,
but I definitely said the
most incorrect answer.
- That was definitely the wrong answer.
- I felt so bad, I was like--
- Just politely decline and be
like, "Oh, thank you but no."
- I know, but like I was at that stage
where I like I really couldn't say no.
Like it was at that point
where I didn't know any better, right?
That was like probably like my
second signing session ever.
- Yeah, you mean like the
story I told was Sydney
where you don't know how
to react in the situation.
- Yeah, you don't know how to react
and because you don't wanna
like make them upset, right?
Because they've lined up all this time,
you're like, "You fucking lined up for me?
Like I'm not anything special."
So like that was at the
point as well where like,
any absurd thing that they would request,
I would just fucking do it
just to make them happy.
So I remember like at this
like Canada convention,
the first dude that
came up to me was like,
"Can you sign my ass?"
I'm like, "Oh, okay."
And like I thought it was
like just his pants, right?
This guy fully fucking
ducks like his pants off.
Shows his--
- In the middle of the
convention fucking booth?
- First dude in the line
plants his bear us on the table
and was like, "Sign here."
(laughing)
- Did you fucking wipe
down this table afterwards?
Oh my God.
- You gonna need some mad sanitation.
- Yeah, I mean, you know, there's
a bottle of hand sanitizer
in case of anything,
I just fucking emptied
this shit, sanitize.
- That's so disgusting.
- I know.
- I think I would vomit on his ass.
- Yeah, so like I signed him making sure
not to actually touch his
ass like with my hand.
I did it and I was like--
- I need one of those like
garbage picking up things
and just like fucking--
- It's just the tongs.
- Yeah, yeah, the tongs
like from far away.
Wear like a radioactive
suit on, Jesus Christ!
- Like, you know, that again,
like that was the point where--
- What is wrong with anime fans?
- I don't know.
- What the fuck!
- Like, I didn't know
any, and same convention
as the guy who planted his ass,
there was another girl who came up
and she looked really fucking--
- Just what fucking convention was this?
- I think this was OtaKuthon in Montreal.
And then this girl came up,
looked and sounded really
fucking normal, right?
Until she said, "Can you sign my arm?"
And she had like, drawn out like a box
for me to sign on the arm.
I'm like, oh, that's kind of weird.
I'm like, "I have a piece of paper."
And she's like, "No, no, I
want you to sign my arm."
So I was like, all right.
I just had a lot of people
to go through, right?
So I just fucking signed it for her.
And I'm like, "Oh, do you
want like a piece of paper
for me to sign it on?"
She's like, "Oh, no, no, it's okay.
I'm getting this tattooed."
And I was like, "Oh, no, no, no, no, no."
(laughing)
I did a really shitty job ass well.
This was like the most messed
up signature I've ever done.
I'm like "No, no, no, no, no, no.
Please don't do that, I'm begging you."
I actually said like, "I'm
begging you don't fucking do it."
And she's like, "Okay,
I'll think about it."
I'm like, "No, no, no,
no, don't think about it.
Just fucking, I don't know."
- Just don't do it.
- I don't know what it, like,
but that's the thing, right?
It's like, I don't know, if it's because
of my lack of experience of
being in situations like that
or just the fact that
conventions have gotten
so much more calm in
the last like five years
or it's a combination of both
because you don't hear that kind of shit
like last year, right?
- I mean, I feel like things are way
more regulated now honestly.
Because I remember first
time going to conventions,
like some of my first signings,
it was kind of like anything
goes, you know what I mean?
And like last year, they
had like a ticketing system
or maybe it was a year before that,
where they had like a
proper ticketing system
'cause I remember I'd be booked out
to do signings for like an hour
and then it would end up going
for like two hours and a half.
And there was nothing that
like regulated what was okay
and what wasn't okay,
you know what I mean?
- I guess that's like the benefit
of the big conventions, right?
Is that because there are so many people
and they probably know
how popular you are.
Then they're like if you're
signing session is one hour,
then it's fucking one hour
and they'll be cutting off the line.
- And I think also, I think people,
it's gotten more in people's
ideas or in people's heads now
that just because you're
at an anime convention,
social norms still do exist
'cause I remember in the before time
and I can't imagine what it was
like even before I started
going to conventions,
but it seemed like going
to an anime conventions,
just like all rules fell out the window.
You could get away with anything.
- I mean, I watched
footage of like Anime Expo
and like fucking 2005, right?
And like, you know, that was during like
the whole like, glomp and like, yaoi,
like, you know, yaoi pad
thing and I'm just like,
I can't imagine fucking being
there and like staying sane.
I'm like, I don't wanna like walk through
the convention hall with the
fear that a random person
is gonna jump dive at me.
Because it's like, "Well, AX glomp."
- It sounds like an anime convention
to like a survival horror.
Who's gonna invade my personal space now?
- I'm like personally actually
drown on everyone now.
It's like who's next?
- I feel like it's pretty
came from a place of like,
I mean, I assumed that it
was the one time of the year
where they would get to meet anime fans.
- Right, right.
- Unlike outside of that you
didn't get to see them, right?
- Like--
- Yeah.
- But now I mean, everyone's
a fucking anime fan.
- Right, I think that's what it is.
- It's mainstream now.
- All now is everyone goes
to a place to buy anime merch
and get drunk together.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Pretty much, pretty much.
- So it's like, I
understand that back then
probably was a little over the top
because this is the only fucking chance
you get to be a fucking weeb.
Like every other day of the
year you can't be a weeb,
otherwise you gonna get bullied.
- Yeah, I feel like the
golden period for me
for anime conventions where it was like,
you could get away with
things that were like fun,
but I feel like the point where it starts
to get really, really regulated
was around 2016 onwards ish.
- Yeah, as it should 'cause there was
so much sketchy shit
happening in the background.
- Yeah, there was a little
sketchy shit happening around.
- I mean, that was around the time
when the whole like cosplay
isn't consent with anime,
which came out right.
It's like, why would you
even need to write that out?
- That like is a failure on
humanity that was a rule.
- Which we need to see
implement this rule that's--
- Yeah, is like, oh, yes, I
need something written down
on paper to know that being
overly sexual towards cosplays
is a bad thing.
- Yeah exactly, right?
- Like fucking.
- But I remember like,
'cause I've been going
to London MCM Expo for
like a fair few years now.
I remember when, so to
explain the London MCM Expo
is like the biggest kind of--
- Kind of pretty fucking
terrible convention.
- It's a convention inverted commas
'cause it's more like an, it is an expo.
- Just anime stuff and
there's not really anything
to do there if you're like a fan,
it's kind of like you can buy stuff
and pretty much all anyone does
is just hang out with their friends.
- Exactly.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- So there's this grass beds in MCM,
outside of the convention
center, which everywhere used to,
where everyone used to hang
out and I was closed off,
but I feel like some of
my best memories were
when people were just doing like
the most random shit on that grass.
- Oh, the alcohol bottles--
- Yeah.
Were you there that year
where there was the,
they did that that Fight Club?
- No.
- Oh, okay.
- They did a Fight Club?
- Yes, so--
(laughing)
- I don't know why I
have a mental image of
a bunch of weebs beating
each other up is hilarious.
- Like retro music blasting like--
- It was a fight club, but
it was like a fight club.
So, it was like the
equivalent of a mosh pit
or something like that.
But I remember there was like,
you know, there was obviously the usual,
you know, you got the fucking
Jedis drooling itself.
But I remember the funniest one I saw was,
there was these two anime fans
and one was like the
scrawniest short anime fan
who was like vitamin D deficient.
You know, that stereotype.
- That really sick dude, right?
- Yeah.
- Skeletal.
- It's skeletal and then
on the other side was
the fucking biggest,
(laughing)
he wasn't like obese, but
let's say he was a big lad.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He was a big lad.
- Hefty fella.
- Yeah.
And this was like the most
uneven fight I've ever seen.
Like forget about weight
classes here, you know?
(laughing)
- Wait, till they started
punching each other.
- So, I guess they just tried
to like make each other fall over, right?
So this the scrawny skinny
dude fucking full on sprints
into this guy tried to like push him
and he just fucking bounces
off him like he's in like,
like he's playing four
guys or something, right?
And the guy just sits on him.
(laughing)
And that's was the end of the fight.
- Were they all drunk?
- Yes, everyone was drunk.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- Just crushes the poor guy.
- So the convention ends at like 6:00,
but that area is still
full of people drinking,
like they're just outside
just getting drunk.
- It sounds awesome.
I would love to be there
just like a spectator.
- It's kind of fiesta, it's kind of--
- It's kind of fiesta,
but now it's like a little
more controlled version
you can get away with which
is a bit of a shame because I liked,
I liked that kind of thing.
- It was literally like
an off licence in a Tesco
within like 100 meters of it so--
- Oh, that's not good.
- People are just buying,
buying, buying drinks,
drinks, drinks and it's like it's,
and I think the hotel hated it
'cause there's literally
a hotel right outside
that are like what are you doing?
Why are you fucking getting drunk?
- Why is this dude sitting
on this scrawny kid?
- Why is there a fight club?
- Why are people cheering?
- I think it was that fight
club that made the convention
actually called off
thinking of the grass area.
(laughing)
It was worth it.
Anyone who was on that
MCM convention knows that
that fight club was hilarious as fuck.
- Yeah, that sounds fucking awesome.
- Health and safety issues aside.
- It is fun when you
walk to MCM convention,
you see something that
clearly will get shut down
within an hour, you're like,
"I'm just gonna sit and watch this.
If this shit go down, this
shit is gonna be funny."
- I see that shit even
regularly at Anime Expo still
to this day, like
outside of the West Wing,
you know, where all the cosplay are,
I see some shit there where
I'm just like, "Why, why?
Where are the staff,
who's regulating this?
- Can we talk about
how fucking crazy it is
like meeting people who watch your videos,
it's so fucking surreal.
How fucking weird is that?
- I never get used to it.
- I'm like, now I have
like a conditioned response
that I could be like,
okay, this is how I should
respond to like fans.
- Activating execution 101.
- But that's why--
- Activating McDonald's smile.
- But that's why getting
recognized anywhere,
but conventions you're
so unprepared for it
because you just never
get used to that fear
'cause I'm just like, "Man,
I'm just a fucking dude
who talks about anime online."
- I mean, it's already surprising
when people at conventions
like come up to you and recognize you.
But what's weird is where
you're like nowhere near
a fucking convention and it's
just like a random like guy
or girl who's just sees,
like that fucking dude in Singapore.
- Oh my God, oh my God.
(laughing)
Can I tell that story?
- Yeah, you can tell it.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- Okay, so we were at
Singapore convention.
I think it was anime, what was it called?
Anime Festival of Asia
or something like that.
- Yeah, AFA, AFA.
- We're at AFA, Singapore.
And we were in this, we were
outside the convention working,
we were getting lunch or something.
It was me Sydney and Joey I believe.
- And Alan I think.
- And Alan, and Alan, yes.
So there are four of us there
and we were just walking
in one of the, in just like
this random shopping mall.
And then we just hear this screech.
This is like, this is like,
this is like the loudest screech
I've ever heard in my life.
- It was like a banshee screech.
Like you would have thought
like someone came through
with like a truck and was
like running people over.
It was that loud.
- Exactly.
And it immediately
triggered my flight of fight
like instincts, right?
- Everybody turned around
like what the fuck!
- What the fuck is going on?
And all we see is this
fucking kid bolting it
towards Joey, right?
And I'm like, like time just
fucking stopped at that moment.
I'm like, "Am I about to
witness my fucking friend dying
in front of my eyes,
is he about to get stabbed or something?"
(laughing)
- It's like the dude was full
on like assassins creeding me.
Like just fucking like lows fuck like this
just like running towards
me through this giant crowd.
And as the crowd is parting
you can see this kid
just coming straight.
I'm like, "Oh, he's coming
for me, I'm gonna die."
And because he's like
Naruto running almost,
I can't see his hands right, so I'm like,
"This guy is probably got a knife.
Like he's about to stab me."
So I'm just prepared to die.
He stops like right here.
(laughing)
He screeches to a halt and
he says, "I love you Joey."
(laughing)
And like, meanwhile, poop is
falling out of my pants, right?
- Meanwhile, we're just like,
"Ah, okay, Joey is not dead, okay.
Ah, hold on."
- That sounds terrifying.
- Of course, he was terrifying.
- And he's like, "Can
you take a photo of me?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
- Did like Felix say one time
like Southeast Asian fans
are like the craziest--
- Yeah, they are.
- In public they just scream?
- Absolutely.
- Shout out to the Southeast Asian fans.
(laughing)
- Everything was great.
It's only like a whole
different level from like,
like any convention
we've been to in America.
Like I remember watching Joey walk
from one panel to
another, it was basically
like watching Justin Bieber
walk through like, like a pre--
- That's gonna be an ego booster.
- I mean, it felt pretty
good, I don't know why.
- I love it when you're just like chilling
and then like someone
in the line she's like,
"Oh, you Joey?"
"Yeah, yeah, I am."
- I think as well like it
might have been because like
that Singapore AFA was,
it was a first for that
convention for a lot of reasons
because I think I was
like the first YouTuber
that had ever been invited.
And also, I was the first
ever guest at that convention
that didn't charge for signatures.
- Yeah.
- Oh, wow.
- And like, 'cause like I
remember when I was sitting there
like waiting, the staff was
like, "All right, so tell me,
how much do the signings cost?"
I'm like, "What are you talking about?"
He's like, "How much does it cost?
Like five dollars, $10 how much is it?
So that I can tell people in the line?"
I'm like, "It's free."
And like--
- What do you mean is free?
- Yeah, he was like,
"What, what do you mean?
What mean its free."
- They couldn't process that.
- They couldn't process it.
He was like, "What do you mean it's free?"
I'm like, "It's fucking free."
- I felt like some
other guests get annoyed
when YouTubers turn up and don't charge
'cause they're like, "Why
are you just devaluing,
you're making us look like ripoffs."
And I'm like, "Well,
- [Joey] I mean, yeah,
I guess I understand.
Because it's just like--
- If I'm selling something
like a print or something,
I'm like I brought an art.
- Yeah, but that's the
thing, I was selling prints
'cause I was doing a collab
with like three studios, right?
So it's like, people can
just fucking buy this.
- Yeah, I feel like if they,
I shouldn't charge
someone to sign something,
they've already paid the
entrance fee to get in.
- Right, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And then they're like
already buying like
the merch that I came up with, right?
So it's like, I'm not gonna
charge them anymore, fuck that.
- It's like the guy who sneezed on set
on Star Wars charged $50 for a shot.
It's like what, what do you mean?
- I was following trouper number 1200.
- It's like who the fuck are you?
I just I really disagree
with them doing that
and they charge so much, I really hate it.
I think it's so conceded--
- Like give them
something physical, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Like this should be like an item, yeah.
- My signature should not be worth money.
- No, no, no.
- It should be like a
nice little memorabilia,
but I don't know anyone who fucking--
- I think it completely destroys
the meaning of a signature, right?
Like from a famous person, in my opinion.
- I don't know, I would just
I just feel bad charging.
- Yeah, me too even if I'm like
the greatest fucking anime,
I don't know.
(laughing)
- Like the worst like I
would get away with is,
you know, charging, I haven't
even like charged for prints
or anything like that 'cause
I've never done prints,
but, or like-
- Print it's sold out.
- Yeah, so print is sold out,
but at least give them something physical
that's what I would say.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- If, you know, we need
to do something like that.
- Right, right, but again, like,
we're doing well enough for ourselves.
Like I'm not that fucking
desperate to be like,
"I have 500 prints, they all need to go."
- And I guess sometimes the
conventions can't really like,
like pay you much for your
time, so it's like I get it
that some people wanna like
get some prints in there,
you know, to get them going.
- But, you know, that's not really
the reason I go to conventions--
- No, no, no, I know what you're--
- I just wanna fucking meet my fans.
- Anyway, any conventions in
Southeast Asia wanna invite us,
we are all--
- Any conventions in general.
- Any conventions in
general, we are always open.
We miss it so much.
- After this fucking
drought of conventions,
we really need to fucking go to some.
- I mean, like crazy people
and inappropriate people aside
like my God, I think that
thing is like anything better
than meeting someone who is
just like nice and just like,
"Hey, I watch your videos."
'Cause it's so crazy, 'cause
you don't really get to ever,
I know you two usually
say this all the time,
you don't get to see people
who watch our videos.
- No.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because when I see a video
that gets like 300,000 views,
I'm like, yeah, cool,
but then when you see--
- Whenever you see 300
people in your panel--
- Like that's crazy with
300 people in one room
who would wanna meet you
that like blows my mind.
And then like most of them
are so fucking sweet, so nice.
It's like, "Man, I can't help
but just like you want a hug?
You wanna hug?"
- It's also just feel so nice,
especially when it's like
a small convention as well,
where it's like the
ratio of like attendees
to people who know you is like staggering.
- And it's so hard to try
to voice your gratitude
without sounding like that
typical corny YouTuber,
but that's just that's--
- I appreciate you guys so much.
- You wanna hug, ask me I'll give you one,
probably even if you're sweaty,
I'll give you a fat hug.
- I will give you a hug too.
- I just, pressured Garnt to saying that,
Garnt doesn't do that.
Garnt wasn't gonna give you
a hug until I said it first,
just wanna make that clear.
- I'm not gonna give you a hug.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- You know, they're not ranked
enough for Joey size, sorry.
- Yeah, I have ranks.
- Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
- But like, you know, that's
like the other thing as well,
like, I don't wanna
like dwell on the whole
like cosplays consent thing, right?
But like, I feel that--
- You can ask me for a
hug, I don't give a shit.
- Right, but like I feel that like now,
like at least with me, my
general rule of thumb is like,
especially if it's of the female, right?
Like, 'cause I know like,
dudes don't give a shit
if I hug them, right?
Because it's just the fucking--
- Oh, yeah, let me cup your dick.
(laughing)
- Let me hold your balls.
- I'm joking don't do that.
Please don't do that that's a joke.
- Your balls are heavy too.
(laughing)
I feel that like because
of the whole thing with,
especially recently like convs have become
a little bit more sensitive like,
at least my general rule of thumb is
if you're a female or
you're not like a dude
who comes up to me and
like wants to take a photo,
I always ask like, is it
all right if I put my hand
on you right shoulder, you know,
or like I wait for them to
be like, "Can I hug you?"
- I do that but like sometimes
I forget and then I'm like,
fuck, I just did it without asking.
Am I a horrible person, like
are they gonna go online
and say if I can get killed.
- It's only until the last AX
where I like physically
told myself I need to get
into the habit of doing that.
- Yeah, same with me.
Like before I was like,
I was just like trying to read the air,
but now I just straight up
ask, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, it used to just be like--
- Jesus!
- I used to just be like,
okay, I kind of get the vibe
that you're okay with it.
Like that's just risky,
I don't know, yeah.
- Because a lot of them are like,
"Of course you can, why
is that even a question?"
I'm like, "No, you don't
understand, I have to ask."
- 'Cause it's weird, right?
Because now, because, you
know, when we started off,
I don't think any YouTuber
ever thinks they're gonna get,
you know, any kind of attention
or any kind of success.
So, you kind of come into it like
the small person mentality.
Yeah, sometimes you just gotta realize
that you can't get away with that anymore.
Unfortunately, even though
you still see yourself
as that same person who started off doing
like YouTube videos in your
mom's basement or whatever.
- I still feel like that.
- I still feel like
that now, but you know--
- Your numbers don't lie, right?
- You gotta adapt eventually.
- It's sad, I mean, I
feel like I have to like,
I mean, in some aspects it makes you
like be a better person, right?
In general, like I've got an asshole
'cause I will get called out for it.
- Yeah.
- Which is good, but
then also, I feel like,
I have to make sure everything in my life
is completely 100% like
there's no doubt in my mind,
in anyone's mind that I'm
totally like in the clear.
Whereas most people it's like, okay, 90%,
70% I'm not an asshole.
It's like all right, that's enough, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- But, you know, it's kind of,
and also, like I feel as
well when you meet fans
sometimes they're really
nervous because obviously,
they don't know you.
I feel like they're more nervous
to put their arm around you.
And so, I feel like that
like waiting for you
to take the lead, which
is, you know, again,
like it makes it harder 'cause
like, I used to just be like,
all right, I guess if they
seem like they want it like,
oh, where they stand for
the photo because sometimes,
you know, they'll just literally
just stand in position puff
like touching you basically,
okay, then you put your arm.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But yeah, some people--
- And I think that's
like another good reason
why like--
- You should ask.
I need to get the habit, yeah.
- Some of them are like,
"Oh, yeah, of course."
Like they weren't expecting that.
- I mean, I'm sure I'll come
on to this pandemic being like.
(laughing)
- I'm sure the pandemic would
change a lot of the behavior
about what's allowed and
everything like that.
- A million hold a hand photo.
- Although I do love to
have the hold a hand photo.
There's something about that, I don't--
- 'Cause the best part is when they ask
for a hold hand photo I'm just like,
"You get it, you get it."
- Whenever I get someone ask me like,
"Can you do a hold the hand?"
I'm like, "I can one* off
that let's do a hold a hug."
You're just like doing this,
but you're not touching at all,
It's fucking great.
- I wonder if all conventions
will everyone be required
to wear a mask when they finally--
- Probably the first two years.
- I mean, that depends on when
the conventions are gonna open.
- Exactly.
- True, true.
- I doubt that there will be
any conventions open next year.
Yeah, I just don't think,
I don't think the wall--
- Didn't they hold on like
fucking Idaho or some shit?
- Yeah, but I mean--
- Like in the middle of November.
- Yeah, exactly, but, you know,
they're gonna fucking
slammed for that, right?
- Yeah.
- Like, I don't think there'll be
any big profile convention
happening to at least
the second half the year that's like--
- And the whole conventions are like,
"Get that out of here, get that out.
I don't wanna do an E-convention
are you kidding me, what's that?
- I mean, I did a couple
of E-conventions this year.
- Did you actually?
- Yeah, yeah.
I did one for,
I did one for anime con South Africa.
- Oh, yeah, I saw that, yeah.
- I did like a pre-recorded
interview for that.
- Oh, sick.
- And I'm like, I wanted to,
the only reason why I wanted
to do that was because
when the pandemic is over,
I really wanna fucking go to South Africa.
So it's just like, it's
just connection building,
so it's like--.
- Joey should play with five head here.
- Yeah, I don't know.
Like I can't get myself to like attend.
Because like attending
conventions is like,
it's kind of like the equivalent of
when you're like watching
a food video or something
and you're watching this like
these three star Michelin chef
like produce this like
gorgeous looking food
and then you're sitting there
with like your combini meal
and you're like, "This is just the same."
- This is almost the same.
Do you know what I mean?
(laughing)
- You're like tear open the
paper salt like, yeah, I'm good.
- My three star MSG.
(laughing)
- Do you hate it when you
make a fucking great meal,
you got a great or maybe
you order new breeds
and you fucking edit all
before like full minutes
into the like one hour
movie you gonna watch?
I'm like, fuck I'm gotta
put this plate away
or it's gonna get dirty in my sink.
I shouldn't been, I
fucking hate that so much.
- I don't know how to
pace myself with food.
- I don't it, it's like the movies,
my popcorn eaten before we even we--
- That's why I don't even
order the popcorn, all right.
- What do you mean?
Why don't you do that?
You fucking animal
- I don't order popcorn, yeah.
- It's so good here, why
would you not want it?
- 'Cause its fucking awful.
- Popcorn is that thing
that I never get myself,
but whenever someone
else's offers I'll do this.
(laughing)
It's like have you guys
had any creepy experiences
with people or fans?
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Yeah, keep saying.
(laughing)
- Because I'd say like this,
the moment when I stopped like
where I had to like really pay attention
to who I always hang out with was
'cause of this one convention I went to.
The thing was like three, four years ago,
I can't remember exactly
how many years it's been,
but it was like my first proper,
creepy stalker experience.
- Sounds like a YouTube title.
(laughing)
- I feel like that your
story animation title.
- Yeah, exactly so--
- Why are you wasting
us at the podcast, man.
Make your story a little bit later.
(laughing)
- I just feel like I
can draw my life, right?
But yeah, I was at this convention
and there was like a communal area.
And, you know, at conventions,
what I like doing at conventions
is meeting random people.
Meeting fans, talking with people.
And the thing is I've met, like
a lot of my closest friends,
I've met through conventions.
Like our friend group in England,
90% of those people were
people who I met at conventions
and were fans of me.
So that's why I had always tried to like,
you know, be as open as
possible no matter who it was.
And I feel like this was
the point when I realized,
"Hey, maybe my reach is a
little bigger than, you know,
what I'm comfortable with."
Because I was with, you know, hanging out
with just this random group of people.
And it was me and Sydney.
And we were, you know, we
were having a great time,
we were just chatting shit
about anime and other shit
and like, in this middle
of this convention hall
and then it was like, you know,
it was time to just disperse
and go in own ways.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- So me and Sydney start
walking back to our hotel rooms
and everyone else goes their own ways.
And then this one kid starts, you know,
starts walking the same
direction with with us, right?
- Is it the same guy from Akihabara?
- No, no, no, it's not the same guy.
Compared to the guy in Akihabara,
the guy in Akihabara was like
a fucking saint, you know?
- Yikes.
- So this kid follows us and I asked,
and so I was trying to
be polite to be like,
"Oh, well, you know,
where are you staying?"
And he was like, "Oh, I'm staying
in the same hotel as you guys."
Now, keep in mind, you
know, I talked with the kid,
you know, quite a bit, you know,
when we're hanging out in a group.
- All right, so you
thought it was plausible
that you told him your hotel.
- Yeah, yeah, it's, and I was,
you know, I wasn't wasted,
but I was, you know, I
had a few drinks in me
and I was feeling friendly,
so I was like, whatever,
just making casual chitchat
and he seemed normal enough.
You know, he didn't seem like
a creep or anything like that.
And so, we go back, we go to our hotel,
and then we get in the lift
and then he goes in the lift with us.
And we're like, "Oh, what floor are you?"
No, no, sorry, so we get we
get in lift and I hit my floor
and I ask, "Oh, what floor are you?"
And he goes, "Oh, it's
the same floor as you."
- Oh, no.
- And at this point nothing
clicked in my mind, right?
'Cause I was so innocent
at that point I was--
- Oh, there's lots of
rooms in that floor too.
- I know, and both me
and Sydney were like,
"Oh, what a coincidence, you
know, we're on the same floor."
Well, that's a huge
coincidence and at this point,
I'm just like, no, I just
wanna go to my bed and sleep.
I'm way too tired, so I'm like,
"Yeah, cool, that's a huge coincidence."
So we go up to the floor and then,
so I go in first, I go to my room first
and Sydney is just right bit behind me
because I'm tired as fuck,
I just wanna get into my hotel room.
And so, I go to the door
put my key in, I turn around
and the kid is still
there and I'm just like,
"What are you doing?"
And he straight up tells me,
"Oh, no, I just completely lied,
I just wanted to see
where you were saying."
And I'm like, "What the
fuck do I say to this?"
And then apparently,
when I wasn't looking
before I had asked that he tried to go in
for a kiss with Sydney
and Sydney told me this
after we'd got in our hotel room.
And then after he said,
"Oh, no, I'm lying.
I just wanted to see where
you guys are living, bye."
And he just fucks off.
I'm like, what, do I call security.
What the fuck!
'Cause I didn't even get his name,
so I didn't know who this kid was,
it was just this random kid that I'd met,
he knew who I was obviously,
but it was this random kid who I had met
just like on the convention floor.
And so, this was the
first time I'd had like,
a fucking freak out of
my hotel room to be like,
"Yo, shit, we gotta call security."
Would it be like, "Can
we get like Chris Jones
to stand outside this door,
do we change hotel rooms,
what the fuck do we do?"
And that was the exact
moment when I'm just like,
"Okay, I gotta be fucking careful
about who I hang out with at conventions."
So if I'm a bit standoffish
when I meet someone new at conventions,
blame that guy, okay?
- Yeah, that's what the PTSD comes from.
- That's where the PTSD comes from.
- Oh, shit, what the fuck, that's creepy.
- I had something kind of similar to that.
I mean, I've had multiple
experiences similar to that,
but I think the creepiest
one that I ever had was,
it wasn't even in a hotel
room, you know, I was staying,
it was like the first time,
so I've been to Otakuthon in
Montreal a couple of times.
- Yeah, everything is fucking
weird out there, God, damn.
- I got nothing against Montreal,
Montreal is a beautiful city,
but all the weeb shit
happened to me there.
So I was staying at my
friend's place at the time
'cause he lived like five minutes
train from the convention,
so I'm like fuck it, I'll stay at his.
And we were staying with like
a couple of other friends.
And this is before the convention
had even started, right?
But I was a guest at that convention,
so people around Montreal knew
that I was gonna be at that convention.
And it was like midnight, right?
Like 12:00 a.m. and I
was just fucking around
with my friends and we
get a knock on the door
and there's like, and I was like, "Okay."
I open the door and there's
just the box sitting there,
like not even a package, like
not even mail, just a box.
And I'm like, "Is this a bomb?
What is this?"
And I told my like the friend
who, you know, the place,
I was like, "Did you get a package?"
And he's like, "No."
I'm like, "Did anyone here get a package?"
He's like, "No."
- What's in the box?
- And then I flipped the box
over and it says to Joey.
- Oh my God.
- And I was like, "Oh my!"
I fucking like looked around was like,
"There's no one around."
So I took the box in,
I don't know why the
fuck I took the box in.
I took the box and close the
door and I slowly opened it
and it was a Tupperware container of,
you know what poutine is?
- Yeah.
- No.
- Poutine it's this like dish in--
- It's cheese in chips.
- It's cheese in chips
basically with gravy.
It's like a French Canadian thing.
- I fucking love cheese in chips gravy.
- Yeah, Poutine is
fucking delicious, right?
But there was a Tupperware full of poutine
and on top of the Tupperware it said,
"I'm a huge fan of you Joey,
I made some poutine for you."
(laughing)
- Was it still hot?
- It was still hot.
- How did she know where you're staying?
- That's exactly what I wanna know.
That's why I was shitting my pants.
- Wait, wait, wait was it good?
- I didn't eat it.
- What the fuck, I would eat that.
- No.
- Dude, okay, one time--
- I've seen Higurashi
dude, I've seen the scenes
where you eat the fucking ohagi
and there's a giant
needle inside, all right?
I wasn't gonna have that shit.
- All right, one time, right?
I got gifted like a whole as bento box,
like a legit like big ass bento box.
It's sort of had curry in
it, like a little curry.
And I wasn't gonna eat it,
but I was in the hotel room,
it was like 12:00 a.m.
I was fucking starving.
So I remember I had the
bento box in my room
and I take this curry and I
didn't have like a knife or fork
so I'm like, I'm in a fucking hotel room,
but I have like the ice
pick thing like knife.
It was like a fork like two prongs,
so I'm just fucking scooping up this curry
and I was eating it and it
was fucking tasted so good.
(laughing)
It was such a good curry.
- Oh, no, I fucking remembered it like--
- Yeah, I was like so fucking
ghetto eating that with
like my fucking ice pig.
- Yeah, I wouldn't do that.
I just remembered though
with the poutine thing.
I didn't eat it because I
was too fucking scared to,
but my friend was like
fuck it I will eat it,
it's still warm.
But then he ate it and the
first bite he took he was like,
"Why is there a giant hair in this?"
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
- There's none of that in the curry,
the curry was clean good.
- Yeah, and I'm like,
they could be two options
here either one she
or I'm assuming it's a girl
she accidentally like drop
the hair in or she was like,
"I'm gonna get Joey to
eat some of my hair."
- My DNA.
- Yeah, my name is inside Joey.
I'm like, oh, just thinking about it,
shit was just so fucking creepy.
- I'm gonna be an STO Joey.
- I'm gonna be at the top of his ranks
when a part of me is inside his stomach.
But yeah, just a fair warning for anyone
who wants to like gift us
anything, don't gift us food.
like especially if it's hand made.
- Unless it's real bomb, then
I'll still eat it, but no.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm
not gonna eat something
unless it's like packaged.
- I'm fine with food as long
as it just doesn't appear
in front of my hotel room
'cause the weirdest thing I would say is
when people know where
you're staying in the hotel
and regardless of whether
you're a fucking famous YouTuber
or not that shits weird,
you know what I mean?
- I mean, yeah.
- I mean, it was the
creepiest Uber Eats delivery.
(laughing)
- I wouldn't eat that
man, I was just playing.
- I mean, I just ate.
Like I literally just eaten
like stall bought poutine before hand.
- Always the one for more man, always--
- Yeah, that shit fills you up by the way.
- I know, but--
- Plus it's fucking delicious.
- I haven't had anything like that,
I've been lucky enough to like not be--
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I'm surprised you haven't had this--
- If anyone was that must
have creepy fans its you.
- Come on, guys step up, come
on I need more story up here.
I mean, sort of, I guess kind of.
Okay, one time in this convention,
so typically, they don't
put you on the first floor
like they're not supposed
to because obviously
that's where all the elevators are
and everyone's, all the people are there,
so typically they're actually
put guests on the first floor
and they normally have a floor
that's specifically for staff and guests,
it's like separate so
that no attendee should be
on the same floor as a guest or a staff.
That's what they're supposed to do,
but sometimes the Cons don't do that.
So I'm in one of them, I
was on the first floor.
I was kind of annoyed
'cause I was literally
about 15 meters from the elevator.
So everyone knows where I come from.
- A great placement.
- Yeah, right next to it.
- I come from where do I go?
- Exactly, call Nigel.
(laughing)
So it was just like asking someone to see
where I was staying, I'm sure
most people saw where I was.
Luckily, I took advantage of that,
but at about like 2:00 a.m. one night,
I'm like basically naked,
but I really wanted ice
and the ice thing was
right next to the, my room.
(laughing)
And thought mission impossible, right?
It's 10 seconds in and out no problem.
I'm in my boxes only, right?
I'm still gonna fucking
do it, like I don't care.
It's only me, who cares?
I'm like building myself up confidence.
I could just put a T-shirt on,
no, I'm building myself up.
I opened the door and there's
just two kills sitting there
opposite my door.
And I'm like, what the fuck,
I've been like, fucking
SpongeBob has been on
like full volume in my room
dude like what do you--
- And you're naked?
- I'm like basically naked,
I'm like, go to the ice machine
and I get it and I go
back in and I'm like,
as I'm closing my door I'm
like, "What are you doing?"
Like nothing, I'm like, "All right then."
- Did they know you?
- I didn't even ask.
I had to close the door and
they said nothing, I'm like,
"All right, I'm going back to bed."
- Meanwhile, they were like huge fans
and they just creaming themselves.
- Maybe, maybe, I mean,
based on watching one
of my cosplay videos,
so it's not really like a big deal.
- I saw Sidova's nipples.
He came out watching sponge bob--
- They're not on YouTube,
so it's not a big deal.
- For some reason he came out
of his hotel room butt
naked watching SpongeBob.
I didn't even wanna ask
why he was doing that.
- I just wanted ice, you know.
And one time I was on
like the seventh floor
in like Minneapolis and I went to my room,
no one else on this floor,
there's just this like
seven foot white dude,
just sitting in front of my door.
Just sitting in front of
it, literally blocking it.
I was like, "Hey, can I get into my room?"
He's like, "Oh, yeah, sure."
- Yeah, I've had that plenty of times too.
Like people, random people
sitting in front of my door.
And it's almost always people
who don't know who I am.
- Yeah, because like, "Why are you here?"
Because it's like at conventions,
hotel rooms just become a fucking zoo.
Yeah, you know what I mean?
- I was just so confused.
I'm like, Okay, like,
he was literally like,
not even like next to it,
like in front of my door.
And I like kind of like, I'm
like, "Hey, can you move?
I'm gonna get into my room."
- Like why do these like
attendees think that are
like hotel hallways are the
same as convention hallways,
you can't just sit in my hallway.
- And I didn't say
anything 'cause I was like,
I'm gonna hope that when I
leave this room in 20 minutes
after I've had my shower,
he will not be there.
Luckily he wasn't.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I was like, that was just so weird.
- You've never had like the
getting of letters slipped
under your hotel door
and stories like that?
- Or people still get back to your room?
- No, they always like give
it to my face, which is like--
- That's so much nice, I wish I had that.
- I had someone who's like this is for you
and it was an envelope.
- Yeah.
- I thought like that's nice,
maybe he could be a little cunt.
I noticed like it's a little light.
And the helper next to me is
like, oh, you should open it.
I was like, I was gonna leave it,
something like leave it till I get back
'cause people are still
coming and I opened it up
and it's a hotel key card.
And on the envelope, they've
written their room number.
And I was like damn.
- Damn son.
- And then the handler--
- Did you go?
(laughing)
- No.
- Maybe straight, any dude
watching this is like,
it's free invitation.
- It's like a fairy tale
cosplays, so I was like,
"No, thank you."
(laughing)
I'm kidding, I just thought this is not
the kind of Chris Hansen
trap I need to walk into.
I'm like this is, "No, no, no, no."
This is like a James Bond
plot, but no, thank you.
And like the handler next
to me was like, "Damn."
- He was like, "Can I have that?"
- Yeah, I was like, "Do you want it?"
I asked him to give it back to the hotel.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, people did give me
like numbers or something.
- Yeah, I mean, like--
- It's just flattering,
I'm like, "Thank you.
Babe, you think I'm the one
texting, you are the one,
God, get outta, get outta here you."
I like it, I don't know, it's nice.
- Yeah, I think the
nicest gift I've ever got
from a fan was, it was at AX where--
- A lot of my enemies.
- So someone had given me
also like handwritten letter,
but with the letter was
like, it came in a box
and in the box was like
a lot of origami cranes
that she was like fold it herself.
And I'm like, "Did you
do this all by hand?"
And she's like, "Yeah,
you know, I was just bored
and I just wanted to give you
something that was memorable."
And it was definitely
memorable because it was like,
you know, I was like--
- I mean, you're telling the
story of her right now, man.
- Yeah, exactly, I still
remember her to this day,
I still have it.
Fucking, it was the
first time I felt like,
maybe I'm doing some
good in this world man.
I'm so happy, thank you so much.
But yeah, it was just--
- I was talking about animated titties
and I get this beautiful gifts.
- Have you seen like the vine or whatever,
where the guy is making
a sandwich with crisps.
He's like, "You made this for me?
Bro, you made this for me?
I love you, bro."
That's how I fell in
that exact moment, right?
- Do you remember that like
really creepy statue I had
at my house?
- Yeah.
- I love this, I loved it.
A fan had made me the statue
and it was like a proper clay statue.
And it was like, you know,
I don't think they were
like amazing in it,
but it was so fucking sweet,
but it was so cursed and
creepy at the same time.
But it was such, so I
just couldn't imagine
the amount of thought they put into this
that I fucking loved it so
much so I kept it in my house.
So whenever anybody came
to my house, they're like,
"What the fuck is that?
What is that?"
I'm like, "Oh, it's a statue of me."
They're like, "You, that's you?"
I'm like, "It's not the most flattering,
but a fan gave it to me."
They're like, "Oh, that's nice."
Yeah, blah, blah, blah.
- Yeah, probably because when
you say it's a statue of you
is like did you make that?
- The thing was as well as
is that it kinda looked really beat up
because it like went
through the mail as well
and I had to like, I thought
this thing was so cool,
they done it that I spent
like an hour and a half
super gluing it all back together
just so I could display it in my house
and creep everyone out
I guess by accident,
but I thought like,
"Oh, this is so sweet."
And now that's in my parents
house creeping them out.
Thank you that one fan who
sent me that statue of me
in like an owl pose.
- Yeah, we appreciate that
shit so much honestly.
- Yeah.
- We don't do anything that amazing
to be able to get gifts like that so.
- Like being given anything
it just feels really weird
that you would, you know,
want to give something to us anyway.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- And not weird in a bad
way, just weird for us
because we're just like, we
don't do anything special.
We just fucking talk about--
- Fucking make videos.
- Comment on anime titties and whatever.
- It's very humbling 'cause I again,
I feel like I make the
videos just for myself and,
you know, just to pay the bills
that's kind of like the main reasons,
you know what that like,
I make the videos first
and foremost for me
and then it's just like,
I constantly forget
how much people enjoy them.
And it's really just like,
"Oh, shit, these mean things to people?"
Not that my videos are like
worth meaning anything,
I don't mean that, I'm not
considered at all to think that,
but other people were
like, "Oh, you know--
- My videos are deep.
- Right, like you may say issues like,
"You know, I'm doing this
'cause it keeps people happy
without me to pressure you to go up 10%."
- I'm changing the world,
you might react that way.
- Yeah, it's like, you know, I get it.
Some people it's like that routine
because I thought that if someone's video
even though it's dumb is like,
you know, maybe help me out.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I've just come to, I don't know, man.
It's hard to explain.
- It's always nice,
it's always humbling because
what we see on our side
is just a number.
- It's so, yeah.
- A number means nothing, but
when we go to a convention
and we see a room full of people
and it's like putting of
like actual people and faces
and interactions to
those numbers it's like,
unless you've experienced that
you can't really describe it,
you know what I mean?
It's very humbling and
it's very flattering
and you don't quite
know what the right way
to react to it is.
So we just hope that we
react in a way that one,
doesn't make you feel bad
and two, doesn't make us seem
like conceited ourselves in anime as well.
- I just want you if you know
me and you come up to me,
just have like, go away from
that interaction thing of,
damn, always everything
I wanted them to be.
That's all I want and it's so hard
because sometimes I'm like,
did I say the right thing,
should I have squeezed them
a little harder with the hug,
should I have shaken their hand longer?
- Like sometimes every
time after convention,
like I wake up in a cold sweat to be like,
"Man was I an asshole to that one person."
Like I was just trying to get food, like--
- Like we gonna get canceled,
we gonna get canceled.
- And it's also like, you know,
'cause some people they
always like want a little more
and it's hard 'cause you like,
especially if you're
going out for like dinner
with your anime friends, it's like,
oh, man, I really don't
want them to be like,
"Damn, Connor is an asshole,
he wouldn't let me eat with him."
And it's like, "Well, I mean--
- Yeah, for some reason,
I don't give a shit about
the one hate comment or like the haters--
- I know, right, right.
- Oh, you see on a YouTube comment,
but the thoughts of this guy
trashing me to his friends,
just fucking keeps me up,
that fucking keeps me up at night, man.
- It's so real, right?
It's so real.
- I could be totally in the
right and being fuck off,
but I can't do it because I'm like,
"Man, this guy respect me so much
and I really don't wanna be mean.
And I'm trying to explain it so nicely,
but he's just not getting it sometimes.
- Because, you know, there's
a little part of you where
if the roles were reversed, you'd be like,
"Man, I think I was a fucking asshole."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I get it.
- Which, by the way,
shout out to that guy I met in Akihabara,
who I told the story about for
being a good sport about it,
you know, it was an awkward interaction,
but thank you for being
good sport about it.
You know, I saw your
comments and everything.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, yeah, I mean--
- Yeah, bottom line, we
appreciate every single person
that comes up to us.
It's just that sometimes every
now and then there's just
that one really weird person.
- Just like, you know, social--
- Just be a norm, just be you.
- Just be you.
Understand that social norms
do exist in anime conventions--
- Basically, you know, pretty
now, you're trash taster,
you're my dude now, come on.
- Just okay, I think
the best way to what is,
treat us no differently how
you would just treat a stranger
'cause, you know, it's
how I would explain my past relationships
where I've watched people,
you know, on YouTube
that, you know, you do
feel like a connection with
because you feel like you do know them,
but you have to understand that
that's a one way connection.
You wouldn't go up to a
random stranger and be like,
"Yo, bro I know everything
you've done, you know,
I know your entire life
story, let's be friends."
You know, there are
several steps for both ends
when it comes to making friends
whether you know the person or not.
And our perspective is, we don't know you,
you know what I mean?
So as long as you just come
in with that perspective--
- That is the worst
question I hated the most,
"Can we be friends?"
It's the worst question.
Because is like--
- It's so loaded.
- Like how on earth do you
expect like me to answer that?
Like, "Yo, we're best friends,
here's my fucking phone number.
We're going on vacation next week,
why don't you come join us?"
- By the way, what's your name?
- It's so--
- You don't make friends
by asking someone, "Can we be friends?"
- Right, like, I feel
like asking that question,
you never win as the person
asking that question,
you're gonna get what you
want and you all you're doing
is making the situation
awkward for everyone involved.
I have to explain to you be
like, "So, I don't know you.
I would like to, you know,
I'm happy to talk to you
and get to know you a little better.
- And I hate that talk too
because it makes you sound
like an asshole, right?
- Yeah, I don't wanna,
'cause it makes me feel
like I'm like putting them below me.
Yeah, you don't have
the right to be friends.
It's not like that.
- You don't have enough subs to be like--
- Right, but it's so difficult
because there's no way
of really explaining that
without making it sound like
you're in the better position
with like, "Hey, no, no."
- Yeah.
- Well, the way I would think about it is,
I mean, like I said, "You
wouldn't ask a person that you,
whether they're famous or
not you've just met kinda,
"Hey, can we be friends?"
- True, true, true.
- Like 90% of the time,
they're gonna be like,
"I mean, I don't know you
and you don't know me."
- Who are you?
- Yeah, like can we get
to know each other first--
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And then we can decide.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But not through asking that question.
- True.
- Now I'm actually just curious,
like once conventions do
start to open up again,
I wonder how many people are
gonna come up to us being like,
"Yo, Joey from Trash Tastes, right?"
- Oh, Trash Taste as opposed to channel?
- Yeah, as opposed to like the Anime Man.
I'm genuinely curious.
- Who knows man, who knows?
- Because I'm sure there's
like some Trash Taste viewers
who don't watch like
our individual channels.
- Oh, for sure, for sure.
- Or probably don't, never knew us
before Trash Taste, right?
So I'm just curious like who's
gonna be the first person
to be like, "Yo, it's Joey,
Garnt, Connor from Trash Taste."
- I've gotta love that.
- That's gotta be fucking cool.
- I just miss, I just miss all like
all the mispronunciation of my username.
I have like a fucking list of
all the missed pronunciations
of like everyone who's
tried to pronounce Gigguk.
(laughing)
- Dude I get that too and I'm like,
I remember I had one guy
at Anime Expo being like,
"Yo, are you Josh the Anime Man?"
(laughing)
I'm like, "What, it's not even close."
- Wasn't that that one
guy who like, who like--
- Oh, in Singapore, right?
- Yeah.
- Who was like, "Are you Gigguk?"
Meanwhile, Garnt is
standing right next to me.
I'm like, "Ah, no,
that's Gigguk actually."
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- He was my fucking favorite.
- How do you do that?
- I don't know, like,
oh, yeah, it's hilarious.
Well, either way we
fucking miss conventions.
I'm sure if you're a convention goer,
you probably miss convention.
- We would go to any
conventions invite us please.
- Just invite us.
- And honestly--
- I'm sure we have some other
stories that we've forgotten
or something that we can tell.
- Yeah, let's be more in future,
'cause we'll just tell them.
Also if you want us to go
to a convention with you,
when they eventually open
up, the best way to do it
is to like email the convention yourself
and tell them you want to see us
that is by far the best
way to get us going
'cause the owners don't know who you want,
so you have to actually tell them.
Don't tell us, we can't
do shit just saying.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, don't like,
we get so many like
emails and tweets coming
like, "Hey, can you come
to this conventions?"
Is like we-
- We don't make that decision.
- Yeah, we don't make that decisions.
- We get the invites from a convention,
so if there's enough interest
for your local convention--
- That's like saying like,
"Hey, can you go to this
random person's wedding?"
It's like, "I didn't get the
invite dude, I can't go."
- It's like bro you're playing
at this concert, right?
Like you're playing this gig.
- Yeah, can you go to the gig?
- It's like, "No, I can't, no."
Yeah, so let your like,
you know, local convention
or whatever know who you want.
- I wanna go anywhere in the
world even after the virus.
- Yeah, honestly, like conventions,
I fucking love conventions
because it gives me the--
- And whatever travel,
and whatever conventions
wants to host the first
in person Trash Taste--
- whoa!
- Whoa, that's good, that
would be some spicy shit.
That would be some spicy shit.
- That's would be fucking awesome.
In the meantime, though,
look at these lovely patreons
who support the show.
- Damn, I love those patreons, man, damn.
- Yeah, I found to love them.
- These guys are very
normal at conventions.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I bet they'd won't
stalk me, they won't--
- They won't block me, it's alright.
But if you'd like to be
in part of that group,
then make sure to go over
to patreon.com/TrashTaste,
best place to support the show directly.
Also follow us on Twitter
and Reddit, sub-Reddit.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Lots of memes there,
lots of greatness there.
- [Garnt] We love it.
- All right.
- Well, yeah, guys.
- That's it boys.
- Hopefully you enjoyed this episode
and we'll see you guys in the next one.
- [Group] Bye.
(upbeat music)